war das der johannes ist im wifi bling muss man gucken ich weiß nicht welche welche action das
trigger das ist der wifi trigger der gäste wifi trigger ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
es sendet an jede lampe ein flash und jede lampe implementiert flash so ein bisschen anders hat
das so ein disco effekt okay so fancy ist mein home assistant so hörst du uns über die über
des Dings. Aber ich höre Johannes
nicht. Wir hören Johannes noch nicht.
Ich höre mich selber. Ja.
Also auch über den Kopf
höre ich auch selber.
Ja doch, ich höre mich auch selber.
Kannst du mal was sagen, Johannes? Was?
Ah, jetzt höre ich dich.
Ja.
Wird maximal noch zweimal
passieren. Ich sehe schon, wir haben
hier Lichtdisco.
So, und Johannes
hört Johannes selber
immer noch? Ja.
Und hörst du dich jetzt immer noch selber?
Ja.
Aber nicht mehr so doll. Es geht hoffentlich, oder?
Das eine ist das eingebaute Monitoring von dem Headset selber.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausmacht.
Das andere war das Software-Monitoring von Recording.
Und ich hoffe, dass es dich nicht allzu sehr irritiert.
Wenn nicht, können wir auch die Headsets tauschen.
Ja, ich glaube jetzt...
Ja, jetzt geht's.
Vorher war die Latenz schlimme.
Aber es ist immer noch ein bisschen Latenz.
Das nächste Mal kann ich auch empfehlen, dass die Leute ihr eigenes Headset mitbringen, aber ich wollte das vorher ein bisschen testen und ausprobieren, weil ich das Setup von dem Ultraschall hier auf dem Laptop auch gerade zum ersten Mal gemacht habe.
So, dann gibt es hier dieses coole Feature, wo ich das Jingle bereits in diesem Soundboard hatte und wenn ich dann hier drücke...
drücke.
Yes, hallo, es ist
akronomisierbar, Folge 56.
Hi Kilian. Hi Hendrik.
Hi Johannes. Hi Kilian. Nimm mich schon auf.
Ich bin doch gleich fertig.
Ja, ich dachte immer, das Jingle wird nachher
reingeschnitten. Das wird doch meistens nachher reingeschnitten.
Aber diesmal würde ich es mal so probieren.
Du sagst jetzt, ob du so ein Soundboard hast,
wo du immer wild drauf rumhaust.
Das ist doch alles.
Ich bin wirklich noch nicht fertig.
Ich habe hier Ultraschall, jetzt die neue Ultraschall 5, auf dem anderen Rechner habe ich noch Ultraschall 3, weil ich mich nicht getraut habe, das mal neu einzurichten.
Aber es geht super Pilleballer einfach.
Es hat literally 5 Minuten gedauert.
Das Schlimmste ist immer das Routing einstellen, was angeblich komplett automatisch geht.
Aber das mache ich trotzdem jedes Mal von vorne.
Und in diesem Fall jetzt momentan haben wir noch ein zusätzliches USB-Gerät,
weil ich mir dieses geile Gerät hier zur Aufnahme gekauft habe,
dieses Focusrite, aber da kann man nur zwei Headshots anschließen,
was also eigentlich ein Fehlkauf war, zumindest fürs Podcasting.
Ich könnte hier noch mehrere Mikros anschließen ohne Monitoring
und noch diverse Musikgeräte.
Aber da wäre ja hier keine Recording-Session machen
und Musik produzieren, vielleicht zumindest noch nicht,
also wenn ihr Bock habt, dann aber auch.
Aber das Ding nutzen wir jetzt auch schon eine ganze Weile, oder?
Das nutzen wir.
Also nicht seit Anfang an, aber schon so mittlerweile seit 40 Folgen oder so.
Vermutlich, ja. Die paar Folgen, die wir remote gemacht haben, nicht, aber schon.
Und auch nicht die, wo wir unterwegs sind, so auf den Datenspuren oder auf dem Kongress.
Nee, wie hatten wir denn die Datenspuren? Oh, die Datenspuren-Folge haben wir im...
Das ist nämlich gerade die perfekte Überleitung, weil wir haben auch vor fünf Jahren bei den Datenspuren aufgenommen.
und es ist in einem Monat, also
in einem Monat und einem Tag ist es
vor fünf Jahren und da war Johannes mit dabei.
Ja. Oh Gott, stimmt.
Das waren die Datenspuren.
Also noch welche das waren? Also vor fünf
Jahren, ja. Das waren die Datenspuren beim
beim, äh, im Dingsbuss.
Die ersten im Zentralwerk, oder? Ich glaube, ja.
Und die davor waren, die
aber im,
technische Sammlung.
Und da hat nur dieses eigene,
da haben wir auch aufgenommen, ja, das habe ich vergessen.
Dieses DDR-Tonstudio.
Das war geil. Das war ziemlich fancy.
Aber vor fünf Jahren ziemlich genauer haben wir mit dir
in Datenspuren aufgenommen. Und deswegen müssen wir dich
jetzt wieder einladen. Ja, ich musste
letztens eh schauen. Ich war schon mal
in einer Folge und habe ich gescrollt, gescrollt,
gescrollt. Das ist ziemlich lange her.
Damals haben wir über
Ada geredet.
Ja.
Ich habe es wieder aufgeschrieben.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, den
Show Notes nach steht Ada auch heute
mit auf der Liste. Man könnte ja nicht
Johannes dabei haben, ohne über Ada zu labern.
Aber damals hast du gearbeitet bei Komponolit, oder?
Ja.
Und das gibt es ja so in der Form seitdem nicht mehr.
Jein.
Also es heißt jetzt AdaCore GmbH
und das ist jetzt eine hundertprozentige Tochtergesellschaft von AdaCore.
Aber ansonsten die Entität als solche ist die gleiche wie früher.
Das heißt, Komponolit heißt jetzt Ada, sonst...
Das reimt sich nicht mal.
Ja, Componite heißt jetzt
AdaCore und
weiter heißt Twix.
Und Twitter heißt Dix, genau.
Ach ja, Tüter.
Aber cool. Das heißt, du bist
am AdaCore
lol, heißt ja auch so direkt mit dran.
Ja. Habt ihr vorher schon an Ada
gearbeitet in der Firma? Wir haben
mit Ada gearbeitet.
Also wir haben vor allem mit Spark gearbeitet
und wir waren quasi schon
Evaluierungskunde von AdaCore.
Also wir haben uns quasi ihren
Spiler und Spark in der Pro-Version für günstiger gegeben.
Und irgendwann haben sie gesagt, ihr kennt euch so gut mit ADA aus, wir kaufen euch jetzt.
Ja, also es war halt so eine, es ging ja ein bisschen von uns aus.
Hallo, könnt ihr uns bitte kaufen?
Ja, es kam dann irgendwann die Erkenntnis, dass das ADA Core Kunden hat, an die wir unser Zeug unter Umständen verkaufen können,
aber dass Edercore einfach auch da die besseren Wege hat, den Leuten das zu verkaufen.
Und wir das halt nicht hatten und dann hat es halt eins zum anderen geführt und wir wurden gekauft.
Cool. Und jetzt aber das für eine große Firma, die Software auf der internationalen Raumstation ausführt.
Geil. Unter anderem auch, ja.
Was heißt groß? Wie viele seid ihr da gekauft?
Ich glaube so 150 Leute aktuell.
Okay.
Habt ihr Code auf dem Mars?
Ich weiß es tatsächlich nicht.
Ich würde es nicht ausschließen.
Ich habe irgendwann noch festgestellt, dass ich Leute kenne,
die Code geschrieben haben, der auf Mars-Rover läuft.
Und das finde ich schon irgendwie so krass.
Das ist schon episch cool.
Ich meine, ich muss jetzt unsere Webseite aufmachen,
damit ich nachsehen kann, was im öffentlichen Internet steht,
damit ich weiß, was ich euch erzählen darf.
Ja klar, auf allen 20 Mars-Missionen.
Ups.
Tatsächlich gab es, irgendwo hatte ich mal eine Liste gefunden
von einem Paper, wo alle möglichen Dinge
draufstanden, auf denen EDA läuft.
Ich versuche, die wiederzufinden
und dann können wir die verlinken.
Cool, cool.
Ja, wir haben dich auch eigentlich nicht
eingeladen, um über deine Arbeit zu reden.
Wir reden schon gerne über Arbeit.
Es gibt so viele andere coole Themen,
über die wir reden könnten.
Bevor wir in Themen absteigen, mal ganz kurz.
Wir haben ein paar Errater.
Nein, haben wir etwa Quatsch behauptet
in der letzten Folge.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Der Helge hat geschrieben.
Ich glaube, der Helge hatte fast einen Autounfall gebaut,
als er uns gehört hat, oder? Was hat er geschrieben?
Was hat er gesagt? Da kuse ich so ganz
entspannt die A2 entlang zurück nach Hause hören,
den Podcast und what the fuck, da muss ich glatt hupen.
Da behauptet tatsächlich jemand,
dass Windows 95 das X im Close-Button erfunden hätte.
Haben wir ja Gott sei Dank
später selber noch den Fehler bemerken, dass wir den Artikel
live on Show gelesen haben.
Es war natürlich Windows 93.
Autsch.
Helge, Vorsicht beim Autofahren.
Aber was ich
sehr interessant fand, war noch der Hinweis,
dass der Next Step Prefix
bei Klassen in der Objective Serial,
wie man ihn eigentlich, wie ich dachte, was NS
ist, die haben wir für NX
benutzt, also NX Window, NX
Host und später das NS kam
dann mit Open Step, meinte Helge,
aber in Klammer nicht 100% korrekt, wo ich nicht weiß,
was das genau bedeutet, aber
nehme ich erstmal so hin, bei NS sind sich die
Historiker, as far as I know, nicht ganz sicher,
aber am ehesten stand das wohl für
New System, sagt er.
New System, okay. Interessant.
Das war mir völlig neu. Und er hat uns noch darauf hingewiesen, dass seit der Microsoft Acquisition, wo wir gedacht haben, GitHub hat ja gar nichts Böses getan und uns ist zumindest nichts aufgefallen und eingefallen. Aber das große Ding ist natürlich das AI-Harvesting, was er mit anspricht.
Ach so, dass unser Code gelesen wird.
Dass unser Code gelesen wird und sicherlich halt auch der private. Davon musst du einfach ausgehen, alles andere wäre naiv. Und das kann man halt schlecht einfach unter den Tisch fallen lassen.
Aber ja, ich behaupte zwar, es ist trotzdem bisher kein riesiger öffentlicher Fuck-Up gewesen. Der öffentliche Fuck-Up wäre, wenn sie die Modelle, die auch auf privaten Code trainiert sind, veröffentlichen. Aber das haben sie ja anscheinend nicht getan. Zumindest ist es nicht aufgefallen bisher. Aber es ist natürlich trotzdem sehr, sehr uncool und so ein typischer Microsoft-Move.
Aber GitHub für private Sachen nutzen, das ist so ein bisschen wie auf Twitter sein Tagebuch schreiben, oder?
Ich habe hoffentlich private Repos auf GitHub.
Da ist jetzt nichts super Geheimes drin, aber eins, was ich am meisten...
Also wenn ich was auf Twitter privat machen, äh, wenn ich was auf GitHub privat machen würde, dann weil es noch nicht präsentierbar ist und ich das irgendwann veröffentlichen würde oder sowas.
Das auch, ja.
Also ich nutze nur meine Docker-Compose-Config für mein Server-Setup, die liegen in dem privaten Repo.
da ist jetzt auch nichts Privates
inhärent dabei, aber
es sind auch keine Hardcoded
Credentials mit dabei, aber es muss ja trotzdem nicht
öffentlich sein, welche Services wo
genau wie laufen.
Aber gut, das ist natürlich gut,
da lebe ich damit, dass GitHub
slash Microsoft weiß, was das
ist. Nicht, dass die groß
was damit anfangen können, weil das
nichts Interessantes ist.
Du könntest dem Ding sagen, schreib mir mal Code, der so aussieht wie
der Code vom GitHub-Account
Kilian Köln. Meinst du, der hat die ganzen Metadaten
dran, wo das originated, der Content?
Das wäre eigentlich meine Hauptfrage.
Kann man ChatGPT fragen,
gib mir mal eine Quelle zu dem, was du gerade behauptest?
Wahrscheinlich hat das sich ja wirklich...
Naja, das ist ja das Ding, was dieser Anwalt aus New York da gehabt hatte,
der sich seinen,
keine Ahnung was,
der Name von den Textes, den er hat, schreiben lassen,
irgendwas, Ausarbeitung
zu irgendwas und hat ChatGPT
nach Quellen mit gefragt dazu.
ChatGPT hat Quellen genannt.
Er hat ChatGPT nochmal gefragt, gibt es die Quellen wirklich?
ChatGPT hat Ja gesagt.
Natürlich.
Wenn ChatGPT das sagt, dann wird das wohl gesagt.
Er hat ja extra nachgefragt.
Und dann hat er das halt eingereicht.
Der Richter hatte den
The Gall, wie man im Englischen sagt,
nachzuschauen und die Quellen zu prüfen und keine davon hat existiert.
Ist halt blöd.
Und da mussten sie halt irgendwie erstmal damit umgehen.
Und ein Novum dann schaffen damit,
wie das Rechtssystem damit umgeht,
dass er wahrscheinlich nicht der letzte Anwalt gewesen sein wird,
dessen Scheiß zu machen.
Aber ich hatte letztens
auf X, was damals Twitter war.
Sag ruhig Twitter.
Ich finde das so schön wie...
Ich sage einfach Twitter. Früher hat man
Birdside gesagt, um dem den Finger zu zeigen.
Jetzt kannst du Twitter sagen.
Es geht viel besser von der Zuge.
Ich finde es aber auch schön, wie einfach
in jeder Pressepublikation,
in der Twitter erwähnt wird,
wird X und in Klammern
Twitter dahinter steht, weil sonst niemand weiß.
Es ist aber auch als Trademark
total bescheuert.
Irgendwann hatte ich auch gelesen, dass wohl Microsoft
der Trademark X für E-Commerce hat.
Ziemlich viele Plattformen haben den Wordmark X für irgendwas getrademacht.
Facebook und Microsoft haben mehr Rechte für die Trademark X im Social-Media-Bereich als Twitter.
Vielleicht ist explizit X.com das Ding, was ihm gehört hat.
Vielleicht ist das der Grund, dass Elon Musk gegen Mark Zuckerberg kämpfen will.
Vielleicht bekommt er dann das Trademark für X im Social-Media-Bereich.
Da muss er aber danach als Hauptboss gegen Satya Natella kämpfen, oder?
Würde ich auch sagen, ja.
Wie ist denn das mit, hier sind gar nicht mal so wenige Spielefirmen,
die irgendwie in der Entwicklung von dem Klassiker XCOM beteiligt sind.
Die haben doch auch irgendwie Markenrechte an X mit einem Mittelpunkt.com.
Guter Punkt.
Ich meine, es gibt auch noch Egosoft, die X und X2 und X3 und X4.
Aber das ist ja sogar direkt XCOM.
Was kann jetzt X.com?
Und hier in dem Logo ist sogar ein Punkt zwischen dem X und dem Com.
Oh nein.
Aber hier ist Hasbro dabei. Hasbro hat auch bestimmt etliche Anwälte.
Oh, Vorsicht, die haben...
Und 2K? Naja, weiß nicht mehr, wie groß die noch sind.
Hasbro waren die mit My Little Pony?
I don't know.
Anyway, wir haben noch einen Errata von der letzten Folge.
Achso, genau. Ich wurde darauf hingewiesen, dass das Tamper Monkey,
die Extension, die ich in meinem Firefox installiert habe,
auch die uncoole Closed-Source-Variante ist.
ich doch lieber Grease Monkey nutzen solle.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen.
Und hab mich dann nach kurzer Recherche
dazu entschieden, dass Grease Monkey die
unmaintainte, uncoole Open-Source-Variante
ist und ich lieber Violent Monkey benutze.
Violent Monkey.
Violent Monkey. Und es hat sogar tatsächlich, also
mein Hauptkritikpunkt an Tamper Monkey, ohne das zu
wissen, dass es die uncoole Closed-Source-Variante
war, ist, dass es einfach scheiß outdated
ist und Clunky UI
und sich beschissen bedienen ließ.
Und Violent Monkey macht das tausendmal besser und jetzt bin ich sehr viel glücklicher.
Das ist interessant, weil ich hatte vor gar nicht
Zeit von Grease Monkey auf
Tempered Monkey gewissert,
weil ich in irgendeinem
Script was auf GitHub mal gesehen habe, wie man
das einfach in Tempered Monkey
importieren kann und es hat bei Grease Monkey
nicht so einfach gehen. Da dachte ich, vielleicht
ist das das neue fancy Ding, was man braucht, aber anscheinend...
Den Import machen sie aber alle recht einfach,
solange du eine Datei hast, die randomstring.user.js
hast und dir auf
Plattform deiner Wahl RAW öffnest,
bieten dir alle diese Extensions an. Hey, willst du
diese Datei einfach direkt das User Script importieren?
Yes, please. Okay, das darf ich
Ich habe mich nie so intensiv damit beschäftigt.
Das gibt es hier als Chrome Extension, als Firefox Extension und als Microsoft Edge Add-on.
Und ich habe heute gelesen, man kann jetzt auch Chrome Extensions in Firefox installieren.
Okay, ich dachte, das sei schon längst ein Ding über diese neue Web Extensions API.
Die sind angeblich kompatibel miteinander.
Aber auch jetzt kannst du, wenn du Firefox installierst und du hast Chrome,
da kannst du, wenn du das Profil, Bookmarks und so weiter von deinem Chrome importierst,
Auch seine Extensions-Telefonen installiert.
Man importiert das von der lokalen Installation direkt rüber.
Zum Beispiel.
Interesting.
Ob man das von einer Chrome-Store-Webseite installieren kann, habe ich noch nicht was für.
Ach, die Web-Extensions waren schon standardisiert, aber man musste die anders packagen für beide Browser, oder?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ich glaube, die haben einfach dieselbe API gehabt, um auf Browser-Schnittstellen zuzugreifen.
Aber zum Schluss, ich habe nie eine Browser-Extension gebaut.
Da gibt es doch jetzt auch ganz neu, wenn wir schon bei Web Extensions sind,
U-Block Lite als neue Extension.
Ich habe bloß gesehen, dass du, Hendrik, das irgendwie auf die Liste gesetzt hattest.
Aber ich verstehe nicht, warum ich das wollen würde,
weil es ist doch viel beschnittener als normal.
Spricht man das U-Block aus?
Ich glaube, das ist alles, was ein kleines U im Namen hat,
wird Micro ausgesprochen.
Micro-Block?
Ja.
Da würde ich ja niemals denken, was du heute davon einigst.
das U ist das alte Zeichen für das
Es soll ja ein Müh sein.
Es ist ein Mikro.
Ein Müh.
Ein Mühblock.
Ein Mühblock, ja genau.
Ja, okay.
Noch ein Side-Fact, sorry, wir gehen von Thema zu Thema.
Ist euch, war euch bewusst,
dass
Omega
ein großes O ist und Omikron
ein kleines O? Ich dachte Omega
ist Omega und
O-Mikron. Oh wow.
Ich meine, ich dachte noch, es gibt ein großes und ein kleines Omega, aber jetzt ist es...
Also eine Elektrotechnik, aber es ist nur Omega.
Ihr habt bestimmt noch nie so viel Griechisch in einem Tag auf einmal gelernt.
Das Alpha und das Omega.
Leider musste ich enttäuschen, jede Elektrotechnik-Vorlesung war gefühlt eine halbe Griechichtstunde.
Aber nochmal ganz kurz zu MyBlockLight.
Hast du das auf dem Schirm, was das damit auf sich hat?
Ich hatte es damals gelesen, ich bin gerade nicht mehr so 100% im Bild, aber es ist vom selben Entwickler.
Die Idee ist auch, dass es jetzt diese beschnittene Web-Extension-API nutzt.
Es braucht halt wesentlich weniger Permissions, um in deine Browser-API zuzugreifen.
Das ist der Vorteil.
Es funktioniert, glaube ich, wie diese Content-Blocker-Extensions auf Apple-Plattformen.
Also das Add-on selber kann dann, so wie ich es verstanden habe, nicht auf den Page-Content zugreifen, was es vorher konnte.
Das kann nur noch hostbasiert quasi Blocklisten pflegen und dem Browser sagen, hey, wenn du eine Verbindung dahin aufgemacht bist, mach mal nicht.
Es gibt irgendwo eine Schnittstelle, wo da quasi, ich glaube, die Sperrlisten, und ich lehne mich gerade aus dem Fenster,
Ich verlinke mal den
Hacker News Artikel
in
unseren Shownotes zum Nachlesen.
Also es gibt, wenn ihr
MyBlock Origin
von demselben Maintainer
gibt es jetzt auch
MyBlock
Lite und es hat
weniger Zugriff auf eure Page,
auf euer Browser
Browsing Content. Also
ich mach das mal als
allerersten Pick mit in die Liste.
Solange wir hier noch
bei griechischen Buchstaben sind,
ich muss jetzt mal richtig hartes Nerdwissen
loswerden. Ich habe früher
mal Star Trek Online gespielt und
ich weiß nicht, ob das
Canonical Lore ist,
aber es gibt dort halt die Omega Force,
die gegen die Borg kämpft
und wie wir alle wissen, ist bei den Borg
Widerstand zwecklos und ich finde es
sehr schön, dass es Omega Force heißt,
einfach weil Omega das
Zeichen für die Widerstand
in Elektrotechnik ist.
Das ist schön.
Nice.
Omega Force gibt's, glaube ich,
im Original-Lore nicht, aber Omega
ist ein,
war zumindest in einer Voyager-Folge ein
ganz prägnantes
Element, was
ganz geheimnisvoll war, was für die Borg
sehr wichtig war. Du hast ja einen ziemlichen Trekkie, Johannes,
gegenüber.
Also super Trekkie bin ich
nicht, ich hab bloß jede Serie mindestens zweimal
geguckt.
Ja.
Oh Mann. Aber so viel erstmal zu
unserem Errata, beziehungsweise dem Erratum,
würde ich fast eher sagen, und kurzes
Follow-Up.
Follow-Up haben wir auch noch für deinen Notify-Bounty.
Ja, oh Gott,
die Geschichte. Also, wo war ich das
letzte Mal stehen geblieben? Ich mach an dieser
Stelle mal eine Marke.
Und zwar hatte ich ein
Bounty bekommen für
die Notify-Rust-Library,
die in einem
Slack-Ersatz
verwendet wird und mir wurden
300 Dollar geboten dafür, dass ich einen Bug fixe,
den ich aber entweder nicht fixen konnte,
weil es die API nicht hergab oder
nicht wirklich Lust hatte, es zu fixen
und zwar gehen
Notifications auf macOS
manchmal nicht.
Ja, dieses manchmal vor allem.
Das klingt nach einem Bug, der sehr viel mehr Zeit
als 300 Dollar wert ist.
Ich glaube, da hat Hendrik auch schon mehr Arbeit.
Ich glaube, ich habe seit der letzten
Akronomisierbar-Folge mehr als 300 Dollar
wert an Zeit in dieses Thema
investiert. Aber ich habe auch ein bisschen mit einem anderen Kumpel
zusammen dran rumgehackt und da ein paar Sachen
gelernt. Aber ich habe noch nichts weiter veröffentlicht.
Zumindest, um
dem Ganzen nochmal etwas Kontext zu geben.
Es gibt NS
Notification Center API
auf macOS.
Das ist alte
API. Und
die funktioniert auf meinem
Mac Mini mit einem
Internet-Chip. Aber nur kurz
zur Klarstellung, der NS-Notification-Center hat nichts
mit den User-Notifications,
mit dem Pop-Up zu tun.
NS-User-Notification-Center. Das ist wieder
was anderes, genau. So rum war es.
Und dann gibt es
UN-User-Notification-Center.
Und für NS-Notification-Center,
das geht meistens, aber
zum Beispiel auf meinem
MacBook Air
M2-CPU geht es nicht.
Und mir schreiben Leute, es geht
nicht und ich konnte es bis dato nicht reproduzieren,
aber auf dem Rechner hier
konnte ich es nicht fixen, weil ich es einfach nicht reproduziert
bekommen habe.
Und dann hat sich
jemand, es gibt diese neuere
API, die nicht seit Jahren
deprecated ist und für die brauchst
du, musst du aber deine Binary
packagen und bundeln und
teilweise code signen, damit du überhaupt
was machen kannst.
Ich glaube, die Apple-Doku
empfiehlt, dass man sich halt so
Sandbox-Credentials
Sandbox-Signing macht und dass man halt
irgendwie mit so einer, ich bin ein Developer, ich darf das
gerade sagen, während
man das baut,
sein Bundle signet.
Und da hatte ich überhaupt keinen Bock,
mich reinzufuchsen. Und es gab irgendjemand, der hatte
unten drunter kommentiert, ja, ich wollte da eh gerade ein eigenes
Crate machen, aber ich sehe, es gibt dieses Crate
bereits, also mache ich das als Pull-Request.
Und hat darauf angefangen, mit der neuen API
quasi ein komplettes Crate zu bauen und
ein Pull-Request aufzumachen, der Pull-Request
heißt V2.
Ich nenne ihn auch manchmal heimlich
den Vergeltungs-Pull-Request.
Aber nee, eigentlich
nee. Aber
der Typ hat irgendwie
mehrere Tage durchgehackt und bestimmt
tausend Zeilen Code geschrieben und quasi für jede
kleine
Frickelei, die mit der API möglich ist,
der hat wirklich komplett ein neues
Crate gebaut und das bei mir als
Pull-Request aufgemacht und hat eigentlich alles verworfen,
was vorher da war.
Wie geht man denn mit sowas um?
Ich weiß bis heute nicht, wie ich damit umgehen soll.
er hat doch seitdem nichts mehr dran gemacht und ich bin
kurz davor, ihm irgendwie zu sagen,
mach doch ein eigenes Crate und ich mach hier
bei dem Mini-Crate, was nicht mal meins ist,
ja, das ist das vom Felix,
ich
mach da irgendwie die Minimaländerung,
damit das die Erwartungen, die es bislang
erfüllt hat, die wieder erfüllt und das
mit den allen Features, die man
haben könnte, dafür kann man dann das andere
Crate meinetwegen nehmen, was ich nicht maintain
muss, aber
als so freundlicher
Maintainer, Mit-Maintainer von der
Library von jemand anders,
von einem dritten irgendwie so einen Monster-PR,
der quasi alles ersetzt
kriegen und dann sagen, danke,
ich maintaine das jetzt für Felix
weiter, wo ich vorher
schon total irgendwie
out of my comfort zone war mit dem Zeugs.
Ich glaube
nicht, dass ich den so merchen
werde. Ich glaube, ich werde dann irgendwann
freundlich, also ich habe seitdem noch ein paar Sachen
darüber gelernt. Ich habe mir, ich habe
auch angemerkt, wenn man sich, also
der Hauptnutzer von der
Notification Library ist ja Tauri.
Und
ich habe nicht viel Zeit gehabt in letzter Zeit dafür, aber ich habe auch
neulich mal eine kleine Tauri
App gebaut und da ist
ein Bundling mit dabei, wenn du
diese Tauri-Dev-Umgebung
aufsetzt, dann sagst du hier, richt mir mal
ein Paket ein, dann fragst du dich, möchtest du das in Rust
oder TypeScript bauen, welches Frontend
JavaScript Framework möchtest du verwenden,
um deinen Frontend zu bauen,
dann kannst du sagen, React oder Svelte oder was weiß ich.
Und dann startest du so eine Dev-Umgebung,
wie bei jedem anderen Web-Framework.
Und zum Schluss kannst du sagen, bundle mir das mal.
Und dann hast du ein Bundle.
Und Code-Signing kannst du Self-Signed, irgendwelche Sachen machen.
Das ist mir was hauptsächlich wichtig,
dass ich das irgendwie dokumentiert kriege,
damit ich Leuten sagen kann,
oh, ihr benutzt meine Lib und ihr wollt was shippen damit.
Übrigens, damit Notification funktionieren,
müsst ihr das bundeln und signen.
Also bei Linux geht es mit jeder, kann jede Binary Desktop-Notifications schicken und auf Mac halt nicht.
Ja, deswegen nutzen, wie gesagt, alle, die irgendwie jenseits davon sind, dieses Terminal-Notifier-Tool.
Weil das gecodet und gebundelt ist.
Das ist eine Binary, die startest du einfach mit passenden Flags und die schickt eine Notification mit dem einen blöden, dummen Caveat, dass das Ding halt immer das Icon von der Terminal-App als Icon hat. Und das sieht halt scheiße aus.
Ja, oder
was halt auch viele machen, ist, dass
einfach irgendwelche selbst gemalten
Notifications hochbubbeln. Die tauchen
dann halt in Mac nicht oft in
dieser Sidebar auf. Selbst gemalt? Ach, ii.
Ja, das gibt es auch manchmal.
Nee, also es geht ja noch weniger.
Dann lieber gar keine Notification-Test.
Vielleicht sollte man die Terminal-Notification-App
neu schreiben, einmal sein,
aber so bauen, dass man ein Bild mit
schreibt. Ja, aber genau das geht halt nicht. Das gibt die API nicht
her von Mac OS.
Auf Linux kannst du Bilder mit schicken.
Ein Bild mitschicken kannst du, aber du kannst kein Custom-Icon
setzen. Du hast das Icon
deiner App.
Das ist blöd.
Oh, warte mal. Wenn du
die Notification aber über Browser-Notification
Dings da kriegst, kannst du
Icons von der Webseite bekommen.
Also wenn du
Safari nutzt. Ich glaube, Safari kann
Icons von der Webseite anzeigen, glaube ich.
Ich nutze das Feature sehr selten.
Deswegen ist auch Desktop-Notifications
so ein bisschen
komisch, weil du kannst halt, also bei Tauri,
weil du kannst, glaube ich, auch aus dem
Webview raus mit
JavaScript-Mitteln Notifications
schicken.
Desktop-Notifications? Also nicht einfach nur so ein Alert
oder so, sondern wirklich Notification-Notification?
Ich glaube ja,
weil du kannst ja als Web-App Desktop-Notifications schicken.
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht,
ob so ein WK-Webview das halt auch kann.
Das stimmt.
Ich sehe das schon in Zukunft,
bei Mac-Apps.
Headless Web Views gebundelt, um Notifications
zu schicken. Letztens hat er mit
eine, was war das, diese AWS
CLI, die React mitbundelt
oder was war das?
Die Chrome mitbundelt, eine CLI,
damit die für die Authentication
dir ein OAuth Pop-Up anzeigen kann.
Dafür bundeln die Chrome
Also wenn du über NPM
die AWS CLI installierst
und schaust, wo du es installierst,
ist da liegt ein Chrome.
Ich habe letztens
den Python
Language Server von Microsoft
Pirate installiert
und wollte die dann in einer anderen Umgebung
installieren und dachte so, ja, ich kenne irgendwie das
also wir haben da halt Umgebungen, in denen halt kein
Internet verfügbar ist aus Gründen
und ich wollte da das PIP-Paket hochladen
um dann festzustellen
oder nein, stimmt, ich wollte es im Zug benutzen und es ging
auf einmal nicht mehr, so rum war es
und dann habe ich
festgestellt, das
Python-Paket für den Pirate-Server
lädt einfach nur
den Pirate-Server, der eigentlich
in JavaScript geschrieben ist, als JavaScript-Bundle
runter und führe den aus.
Ach geil. Und es hat einen Version-Check,
den macht es halt einfach immer.
Das heißt, selbst wenn es das schon runtergeladen hat.
Wenn der Request fehlsteht, dann geht's nicht,
oder was? Ja.
Wer baut denn wieder sowas dumm?
Das war aber bei Rust auch
witzigerweise ein Weile Problem.
Wenn du dein Paket gebaut hast,
die hat es die Dependencies schon,
hat er erstmal geguckt,
ob es nicht neue Versionen gibt.
Das ist ja völlig legitim, kann man ja machen.
Und wenn du kein Internet hattest, dann ging es halt nicht weiter.
Und du kannst, es wurde erst ein paar Versionen später eingeführt,
dass du auch einen Offline-Modus bauen kannst.
Apple hatte auch ja mal diesen Fuck-Up in macOS mit drin,
dass sie zum Starten von einer Binary,
beim ersten Start, glaube ich, so einen Request machen
mit der Signature davon irgendwie gegen Apple-Server,
um zu schauen, ob das irgendwie denialistet ist,
dass man diese Binary nicht ausführen kann,
weil das bekannte Schadsoftware ist oder irgendwie sowas.
War das, ich habe es nicht mehr ganz genau im Kopf.
und da war halt auch der Prozess so dumm,
wenn der Request fehlgeschlagen ist, hat er einfach
einen Busy-Wait gemacht, eine CPU-Auslastung ist
auf 100% gestiegen und dein System
ist hängen geblieben, weil er diesen Check
nicht fertig machen konnte.
Das sah als Schatzsoftware aus.
Potenzielle Schatzsoftware,
von der es Wahrscheinlichkeit ist.
Ich finde,
das ist einfach der perfekte
Trick, wenn
der Virenscanner,
wenn der irgendwas findet, was potenziell gefährlich
aussieht, statt er einfach einen Prozess mit der
höchste Systempriorität, der einfach
alle Cores busy raten lässt und dann kann die
Schadsoftware nicht mehr laufen, weil sie nie wieder gescheduled
wird, bevor
die Ransomware deine Festplatte
encrypten kann. War das nicht
sogar auf Mac so, dass du, wenn
das System throttlet, weil es zu
heiß wird, dann startet es einen Prozess, der
mehr CPU-Priorität
hat als alle anderen und dann werden
alle anderen weniger gescheduled?
So throttet man? Low-Tech
Throttling? Ich glaube, unter Windows
gab es doch auch so einen Idle-Prozess. Ich meine,
Das ist jetzt sehr krasses Halbwissen.
Aber irgendwann hatte ich auch so was gelesen.
Es gibt einen konkreten Eidl-Prozess,
der halt nichts tut.
Und wenn der halt gescheduled wird,
dann macht die CPU halt nichts.
Das ist so in etwa,
wie meine Mikrowelle funktioniert.
Ich meine Mikrowelle auf,
also ich mache manchmal gerne Mikrowellen-Popcorn.
Und wenn ich die Mikrowelle auf 100% pro einstelle,
dann ist sie, macht sie
die ganze Zeit durch.
Wenn ich sie auf 70% Leistung einstelle,
macht sie...
Dann macht sie drei Sekunden nichts und dann macht sie wieder...
Ah cool, dann Mikrowelle macht also PWM.
Aber ja,
es ist nicht falsch.
Es ist absolut richtig, dass es so funktionieren kann.
Naja, es wäre
schon schöner, wenn das Popcorn
nicht mit kurzen Pausen
auf voller Power erhitzt wird, sondern lieber
auf niedrigerer Power.
Ja, aber das ist ja keine Hitze. Das ist ja Mikrowellenstrahlung.
Das funktioniert ja nicht genauso wie Ofenhitze.
Das ist ja auch
mein Fakt, das muss man jedes Mal wieder vor Augen
halten. Wenn du etwas,
um es warm zu machen, eine
Einheit von einer Mahlzeit fünf
Minuten in der Mikrowelle brauchst, keine Ahnung,
und du packst zwei davon in die Mikrowelle, dann brauchst du halt auch
zehn Minuten Strahlung, um das auf dieselbe
Hitze zu bringen wie eine Einheit.
Weil es halt nicht einfach nur
ambiente Hitze ist, die da raufwirkt.
Das ist aber auch bei einem
normalen Ofen so.
Wenn da mehr Masse drin ist, hast du mehr
Trägheit. Ja, aber das skaliert nicht auf diese
selbe schöne, elegante Art und Weise, würde ich
behaupten. In der Mikrowelle hast du den Effekt, dass wenn du
Sachen da reintust und diese Drehplatte nicht
anmachst, dann wird potenziell das eine heißer und das andere.
Ja, aber du hast ja, das ist genauso
was man im Physikunterricht der Schule noch kennt,
konstruktive Interferenz zwischen Wellen, du hast ja genau
diese Hotspots und ich wünsche, man könnte
die mal visualisieren für jedes Mikrowellenmodell, kannst du
bestimmt mit irgendwie passenden Sori.
Du kannst dir, du kannst dir, du kaufst dir
Sandwich-Scheibenkäse.
Oh, das ist eine geile Form von
Visualisierung. Dann legst du den Boden
von deiner Mikrowelle mit
Sandwich-Scheibenkäse aus.
Wer braucht schon krass in Sensortechnik, wenn du einfach
Käse scheinen.
Dann siehst du, wo die
Wellen sind.
Aber eigentlich musst du den Käse eigentlich noch
in den Raster mit...
Es ist ein Zellbutscheibenkäse,
das ist schon ein Raster.
Nein, nein, aber die sind ja zu groß.
Und eigentlich willst du das Kleinkranulare haben.
Du musst da quasi noch irgendwas Thermal Isolierendes
als Raster in den Käse reinmachen, damit du siehst,
ah, dieses Quadrat ist geschmolzen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Käse so gut Wärme leitet,
dass du nicht diese Lokalmaxima trotzdem sehen kannst.
An dieser Stelle könnt ihr uns gerne auch andere Experimente,
die ihr mit eurer Mikrowelle zu Hause gemacht habt,
in die Kommentare.
Wir sind korrekt light in Scheiße.
Wo wir gerade bei Mikrowelle sind
und ich hatte ja vorhin schon mit unnützem Nerdwissen angefangen,
wusstet ihr, dass handelsübliche Mikrowellen
üblicherweise auf WLAN-Kanal 11 laufen?
Das ist tatsächlich exakt die gleiche Frequenz,
nur dass die Mikrowelle ungefähr tausendmal mehr Leistung generiert
als den WLAN-Kanal.
Oder welche Frequenz mein WLAN läuft.
Heutzutage ist es nicht mehr so ein Problem,
weil die meisten Mikrowellen sind halt hinreichend gut abgeschirmt.
Sollten sie auch sein, ja.
Früher gab es halt wohl noch, also gerade alte Mikrowellen,
die halt schon, keine Ahnung, 20, 30 Jahre alt sind
und umständlich nicht so gut abgeschirmt.
Und es kann passieren, dass das WLAN auf Kanal,
weil es auf Kanal 11 liegt, dann auch mal ausfällt,
wenn die Mikrowelle läuft, weil die Mikrowelle einfach...
Also wenn das WLAN schlechter wird, weiß ich,
dass ich auch bei meiner Mikrowelle nicht das Gesicht vor die Tür halten sollte,
um zu schauen, wann mein Pop kommt.
Oder bei dem Nachbar unten drunter, der vielleicht gerade sein Popcorn heißt.
Und für alle, die jetzt Angst haben, dass ihr WLAN ihnen den Kopf grillt.
Ach Quatsch.
Ich glaube, WLAN ist was.
100 Milliwatt ist die Begrenzung und die Mikrowelle hat so 750 Watt.
Da sind durchaus noch ein paar Größenordnungen dazwischen.
Aber könnte man extrem starkes WLAN nutzen zum Grillen von Popcorn?
Ich glaube, das Problem ist, wenn du 750 Milliwatt,
Also brauchst du 7500 Router.
Wenn du die in einen Raum stellst,
dann wird das Popcorn allein durch die Abwärme der Router
schon mehr wahr, als durch das WLAN.
Aber so ein 750 Watt Netzteil
dir einen Router auf der Frage.
Ich nenne jetzt keinen Namen,
aber ich habe von einem,
ich glaube, Kollegen
eine Geschichte gehört,
der irgendwie Antennen
elektrotechnisch an seinem Router
im Garten rumgefrickelt hat,
um irgendwie aus dem Haus bis hinten
im Garten Empfang zu haben.
Und irgendwann von der Flugaufsicht oder vom Wetterdienst oder von irgendwem...
Bundesnetzagentur wahrscheinlich.
Bundesnetzagentur.
Bundesnetzagentur macht das üblicherweise.
...angeschrieben wurde.
Es kann auch der meteorologische Dienst gewesen sein, der über seinem in der Region permanent Gewitter gemessen ist.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau, was es war.
Was hat er denn für einen Piraten-Radio-WLAN da aufgeschrieben?
Also ich meine, das ist schon eine Leistung.
Ja, literally, das ist eine Leistung.
Und ich dachte immer, ich bin schon ein bisschen illegal unterwegs.
Das Lustige ist, in meinem Router kann man den Lender-Code halt ändern.
Und es gibt Länder, in denen es auch 200 MW erlaubt.
Und der Router supportet das halt auch.
Das heißt, wenn man einfach den Lender-Code auf das entsprechende Laden setzt,
kann man auch ein bisschen mehr Leistung einstellen.
5 Watt Wi-Fi.
Ich glaube, mit 5 Watt kannst du wahrscheinlich mehr als deine Funkzelle versorgen.
Also wenn du deinen Karten mit 5 Watt WLAN versorgst, kann es sein, dass da die Vögel aus den Bäumen fallen.
Das glaube ich nicht, aber zumindest sind auch die Gärten drei, vier Straßen weiter noch durchaus versorgt.
Das habe ich vorgestern erst auf Mastodon gesehen, so eine Ansichtsvisualisierung, deine Wohnung und wo das WLAN am stärksten ist, so mit Rot und Grün und Gelb.
und da ist der Router und wo hast du am besten WLAN?
Draußen vor der Straße, in der Wohnung meines Nachbarn, hinten im Garten
und wo hast du am schlechtesten WLAN?
Auf meinem Schreibtisch, der literally direkt neben dem Router ist.
Ja, das ist immer wieder interessant.
WLAN, ich meine, das verhält sich ja am Ende wie Schall
und prallt halt auch von Wänden ab und solche Sachen.
Und das ist mir beispielsweise aufgefallen, als ich früher in die Uni gefahren bin,
In der Mitte vom Fritz-Förster-Platz, wo ja eigentlich kein WLAN-Router steht und viel Platz zum nächsten ist, hat man aber super Empfang mit dem Telefon.
Während man im Uni-Gebäude...
Eduroam, direkt auf dem Telefon.
Ja, Eduroam, direkt in der Mitte vom Fritz-Förster-Platz, wenn der Bus halt über die Kreuzung fährt.
In dem Moment, wo der Bus über die Kreuzung fährt.
Ja, genau. Das ist dann halt auch hinterher wieder weg, dummerweise.
Und dann gibt es halt Räume in der Uni, die dafür gedacht sind zum Arbeiten.
Und die haben deutlich schlechter Empfang als der Fritz-Förster-Platz.
Ich möchte aber übrigens dazu sagen,
dass man sich nicht zum Arbeiten auf den
Frustförsterplatz setzen sollte.
Schon mal davon abgesehen, dass es da sehr laut ist.
Aber ich hätte am meisten gestört,
dass die Toilette im APB
absolut gar keinen Empfang hat.
Und ich fand das so süß damals.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, zu was das war,
ob das zu Ehe zuerst zum Ehe ist der Einzirkel oder was anderes.
Du hast auch zu lange auf der Toilette sitzen.
Ja, aber es stört mich, dass es halt wirklich
null ist.
Stell dir mal vor, du sitzt da
und das Kuppertbier ist alle. Wie sollst du da um Hilfe telefonieren?
Ja, wir hatten auch zu irgendeiner Veranstaltung
an alle Klosen der Fakultät im Informatik-Fakultätsgebäude
so Schilder gehangen mit
WLAN-Rating, so fünf
unausgemalte Sterne und da konnten die Leute
selber raten, wie gut
der Wi-Fi hier ist. Und ja, das war
die beschissene Toilette.
Aber tatsächlich habe ich letztens
ein Projekt gefunden
für den Flipper Zero.
Ich weiß nicht, Kian, du hast ihn ja, das weiß ich.
Also für alle, die es nicht kennen,
der Flipper Zero ist ein
universelles
um es mal so auszudrücken.
Da kann halt infrarot und...
Ah ja, ich glaube, das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Und es gibt auch eine Wi-Fi-Extension
und ich habe letztens ein Projekt gefunden.
Aber mit extra Hardware, diese Wi-Fi-Extension.
Also du musst halt das Wi-Fi-Devboard 1 abschließen.
Ja, also das Projekt, was ich gefunden habe,
nutzt dafür einen ESP32,
der wahrscheinlich einfacher und verfügbar und billiger ist.
Das Wi-Fi-Devboard ist quasi ein ESP an GPIO-Pins.
Ja, und es nennt sich Flipper Zero Wi-Fi Map.
Ich kann das auch einfach verliegen.
Das klingt fantastisch. Und zumindest laut diesem Bild,
ich habe es leider noch nicht selber ausprobiert, weil ich keine Zeit hatte,
zumindest laut diesem Bild sieht das tatsächlich
so aus, als könnte man grob
sehen, in welche Richtung und zumindest in welcher
Entfernung sich WLANs befinden.
Ich glaube, das wird nur eine Visualisierung sein, also
eine Grafik, die die Signalstärke
aufs Daten zeigt. Tatsächlich, ich habe
mir selber mal Gedanken darüber gemacht, wie man
ein WLAN-Radar bauen könnte.
Und im Prinzip hast du... Gibt es nicht irgendeine
AVM-Fritz-App, die genau
dieses Feature hat? Aber das ist auch bloß Signalstärke
über Zeit gegraft, oder?
Wahrscheinlich.
Da kannst du selber durch die Gegend laufen und versuchen,
das im Meer zu grafen.
Ich meine, du kannst es mit drei Methoden machen.
Du kannst halt einfach drei Empfänger aufbauen, dann kannst du es triangulieren.
Oder wenn du nur einen Empfänger benutzen willst,
ich meine, es hat einen Grund, dass die
alten Radare sich quasi drehen.
Weil wenn du einen
sehr stark gerichteten Empfang hast,
dann weißt du halt nicht nur die Entfernung,
sondern auch sehr genau die Richtung, aus der die
Entfernung kommt.
Die Richtung, aus der die Entfernung kommt.
Ja.
Du kannst quasi die Stärke des WLANs über die Drehung mappen
und da, wo die Stärke am höchsten ist, in dieser Richtung,
befindet sich dann das WLAN.
Und dann hast du ja schon alle Informationen, die du brauchst,
um es im dreidimensionalen Raum einzuordnen.
Das ist cool.
Höchstens noch, ich glaube, der eine,
wahrscheinlich kann man die Entfernung nicht genau feststellen,
weil die meisten Router und auch viele andere WLAN-Geräte
ihre Sendeleistung ja dynamisch anpassen.
Es gibt aber bestimmt schon irgendwelche
WiFi-Radar-Projekte, wo
was ich spontan gefunden habe, ist
dieses alte Projekt, wo sie mal versucht haben, ich glaube, da haben wir
sogar schon mal drüber gesprochen, dass man
WiFi nutzt, um quasi durch Wände
zu sehen und sie mit
WiFi unterschiedlichen
also sie nutzen WiFi
um gegen
Wassersäcke aka Menschen
abzuprallen durch Säcke
äh, durch Wände hindurch
und zumindest ein grobes Gefühl dazu haben,
ob potenziell hinter der Tür jemand steht
oder wo im Raum Leute positioniert sind.
Und ich glaube, da sind Sachen möglich,
aber da gibt es sicherlich bessere Taktiken.
Das machst du als Sniper oder warum möchtest du das wissen?
Wahrscheinlich ist das der Ansatz.
Im Sinne von, du bist hier gerade in Rainbow Six unterwegs,
musst wissen, wo hinter der Tür potenziell aus der Seite sind.
Ich meine, ich glaube, das Konzept ist gar nicht so unabwegig.
Ich meine, wir haben ja mittlerweile überall Geräte,
die irgendwelche Funkempfänger sind und halt auch was senden.
Das heißt, man hat sowieso schon eine gewisse Hintergrundstrahlung.
Und es gibt auch im Militär tatsächlich rein passive Radare,
die einfach nur mit der existierenden Hintergrundstrahlung von Radio
und diversen anderen Radargeräten, die halt immer da sind, arbeiten und sehen.
Sie sehen vielleicht nicht so genau, was sich bewegt und wo es sich bewegt,
oder nicht so genau wo, aber sie sehen zumindest, dass irgendwo sich im Raum was bewegt,
weil das zumindest einen Schatten hinterlässt.
Das ist schon faszinierend.
Einfach, weil wir genug Hintergrundstrahlung haben,
um diesen Schatten zu sehen.
Also quasi jedes kleine Funk- oder WLAN-Gerät
eine kleine Lichtquelle, eine kleine Glühbirge.
Quasi, bloß Licht, was du auch durch Wände hinweg sehen kannst.
Also es ist einfach eine andere Art von elektromagnetischer Strahlung.
Immer wenn wir darüber reden.
Ich habe Angst, dass dann Leute irgendwo kommen und meinen, ja, und die ganze böse Strahlung,
und die präht uns ja das Gehirn und man sollte es wieder nachts lieber ausmachen.
Ja, das kann man aus Stromkosten wahrscheinlich echt bald sinnvoll machen.
Ich habe es mal gemessen an meinem Router und es ist ein halbes Watt.
Ich würde ungefähr ein Euro im Jahr sparen, wenn ich es nachts ausmachen.
Ich glaube nicht mal.
Aber die CPU-Leistung von deinem Router geht wahrscheinlich auch runter, wenn du ihn vom Netz trennst.
Naja, es hat 100 Millilowatt Sendeleistung und es sind wahrscheinlich die 400 Millilowatt extra, die CPU dann weniger.
Und was kostet das, was braucht der extra beim Bootvorgang, wenn du das nächste Mal startest?
Vielleicht ist das wieder komplett aus?
Ich will ja nicht ganz herunterfahren.
Nee, aber jetzt meine ich, wenn du dich vom Netz trennen würdest, das, was du in der Zeit sparst, verbrätst du das potenziell beim Bootvorgang gleich wieder?
Das würde vielleicht sogar was bringen, aber der Punkt ist, ich glaube, wenn man zuverlässig Internet haben will und wenn man jetzt nicht jeden Abend sicher Punkt 10 ins Bett geht und erst um 8 wieder aufsteht, ist der Zeitraum, in dem quasi absolut niemand das Ding benutzt, wahrscheinlich höchstens vier Stunden.
Sehr gering wahrscheinlich.
Und ich finde es immer interessant, ich meine, es wird ja viel über Stromsparen geredet und ich habe mich auch sehr damit beschäftigt, weil durch gewisse Dinge meine Stromrechnung auch nicht so klein ist.
Aber die Erkenntnis war, es gibt halt immer wieder die gleichen Stromspartipps und ganz, ganz viele Stromspartipps setzen an ganz vielen Stellen an, die Quatsch sind.
Einfach weil die Geräte, die da laufen, so wenig Energie verbrauchen, dass es überhaupt keinen Sinn ergibt, sie auszuschalten.
Ich habe einen verhältnismäßig modernen Fernseher und der braucht im Standby ungefähr 0,5 Watt.
Und den dafür auszuschalten, es bringt nichts.
Wenn man sich einen Kühlschrank kauft, der einfach besser isoliert ist, dann braucht der Kühlschrank 10 Watt weniger.
Davon könnte ich 20 Fernseher im Standby stehen lassen.
Und das sind halt Dinge, auch dass ich zu Hause jetzt mit meinem Laptop statt mit meinem großen Rechner arbeite.
Das spart hundertmal mehr Strom ein, als den Fernseher auszuschalten mit einer Steckdosenleiste.
Spannend ist, wenn du deine eigene PV-Anlage hast und dann plötzlich anfängst, Sachen nur noch tagsüber zu machen.
Deswegen will man ja eigentlich einen Stromspeicher haben, der dann zu den Peakstunden das genau andersrum dir ermöglicht,
dass du nachts die Geräte betreiben kannst aus dem Speicher heraus und tagsüber, wo du ja eh keine Verbraucher hast.
Das ist ja diese typische, ich meine, das haben wir auch schon mal, diese Entenkurve, weil die einfach grob wie eine Ente ausschaut, diese Kurve.
dass du tagsüber, wo am meisten Sonne anliegt und auch, glaube ich, durch Thermik mehr Wind ist,
für mich nicht alles täuscht, also den Strom, den du am ökologischen erzeugen kannst,
kannst du genau dann erzeugen, wenn die wenigsten Verbraucher da sind.
Und gerade zu der Zeit, wo das wegfällt und die meisten Leute nach Hause
und schalten Konsolen, PCs, Fernseher an, waschen Wäsche und so weiter,
nutzen ihre 3D-Drucker.
Den 3D-Drucker machst du früh, wenn du auf Arbeit gehst,
an, damit er fertig ist, wenn du von der Arbeit wiederkommst.
Häufig, ja.
Ich meine, der Trick bei einer PV-Anlage
ist wahrscheinlich, bei zu Hause zu bleiben, eine Klimaanlage
zu haben und da zu arbeiten.
Dann braucht man auch automatisch Taxi-Bastrom.
Ja, gut. Der Trick ist
jetzt nicht unbedingt, das so
zu planen, dass du es komplett verbraten kannst, aber wenn
du es halt speichern kannst und zu den
anderen Zeiten nutzen kannst, ist es halt optimal.
Ich bin auch immer noch sehr kurz
davor, mir so ein System
zu Hause hinzustellen. Ich habe nur noch nicht final entschieden,
welches genau es wird, aber irgendeine Form
Con-Kraftwerk wird es wohl demnächst sein.
Mit großem Akku
dann, wo ich hoffentlich dann
alles betreiben kann von
also sprich Waschmaschine, Kühlschrank, PC.
Das ist ja das Schöne, wenn du es
einfach in die Steckdose steckst,
dann läuft es halt aus deinem lokalen Netz einfach
zusammen. Das ist ja so effortless.
Ich weiß nicht, ob... Ich glaube, du stellst dich noch
einen Ticken einfacher vor, als es zum Schluss ist.
Aber da können wir gerne mal eine extra
Sendung drüber machen. Ich kenne noch ein, zwei Leute,
die sich so ein Ding schon geholt haben. Den Spaß werde
ich sicherlich dann sehen. Genau. Oder
Du erzählst uns das nächste Mal darüber, was du gelernt hast.
Ich muss mir erst mal einen Balkon kaufen, bevor ich ein Kraftwerk
Ja, ich habe nämlich zum Beispiel auch keinen Balkon.
Wollen wir uns mal den Themen
widmen, die wir uns eigentlich
aufgeschrieben haben. Ach, wer hat ein Thema?
Ja, und zwar
du hattest vorhin erzählt, dass du
Wim benutzt
und es gibt traurige Nachrichten.
Wim? Noch ein Wim-User?
Aber ja, sorry, ich habe das Thema abgelenkt.
Wirklich traurige Nachrichten.
Ja, Bram Mullinar ist gestorben.
Ja.
Wer Bram Mullinar nicht kennt, hat nie Wim benutzt,
weil wenn man Wim startet, das Original
Wim, dann ist es von Bram Mullinar
ist gar nicht mal irgendwie
slash... Ist gar nicht mal so alt geworden mit 62.
Wim Improved Version so und so bei
Bram Mullinar et al. Wim is an open
source and freely distributable
Wim is open source and freely distributable
und das Schöne ist, dass
der Startbildschirm von Wim immer angezeigt hat,
dass man bitte Geld
an die ICCF,
das sind Kinder, eine wohltätige
Organisation in Uganda spinnen soll.
Das habe ich tatsächlich einmal gemacht.
Das ist cool.
Das bekommt man nicht mehr angezeigt, wenn man
NeoWim benutzt.
Da bekommt man
nur noch angezeigt...
Oh, nevermind.
Bei NeoWim bekommt man das mittlerweile auch
angezeigt.
Mein NeoWim zeigt das nicht an.
Welche Version Neowim hast du?
0.9.1.
0.9.1, ganz unten.
Help
Blablabla.
Help Poor Children in Uganda.
Genau. Ah, okay, ich dachte, da bekommt man
Bram Molina angezeigt.
Nee, da bekommst du nicht mehr Bram Molina angezeigt.
Apropos Bram Molina angezeigt.
Ich mag sein Bild in der Wikipedia sehr.
Da steht er mit einer Flasche Braugold
posiert.
Sympathischer Mensch.
Ja, ich meine, er hat
krassen Einfluss gehabt dadurch mit
Vim. Also
viele nutzen es natürlich auch nicht unbedingt, aber
mitbekommen und kennen tut es, glaube
jeder, der Software entwickelt.
Ich habe heute zum ersten Mal überhaupt ein Bild
von ihm gesehen.
Und zwar im Zusammenhang mit
der Headline
Bram Mullina's Programming
Language, Simbo.
Simbo. Klingt ein bisschen wie
Zombo.com. Welcome
to Zombo.com. Anything
Welcome. Welcome. Welcome.
Welcome to Sombokon.
Ich erinnere mich grob.
Es gibt eine HTML5-Variante davon.
HTML5-Sombokon.
Whatever, Kilian.
Zumindest...
Ja.
Das war das Thema.
Was hast du mit Simbu auf sich? Simbu?
Simbu. Ich habe das heute Nachmittag gelesen und ich dachte mir,
ach, das wäre mal eine schöne esoterische Programmiersprache.
Da gibt es einen Artikel drin.
Ist es eine esoterische Sprache?
Nein, es ist keine esoterische Sprache.
Es ist nur insofern eine esoterische Sprache,
dass das eine Person einzeln entwickelt hat und die wahrscheinlich
sehr selten von jemandem tatsächlich
für irgendwas benutzt wurde.
Ich packe das einfach mal in die Show Notes.
Verlink mal mit.
Das weitere, wir haben ja heute
Johannes zu Gast und eigentlich haben wir schon angefangen,
über Ada zu reden und wir haben hier
ein Thema in der Liste.
Wollen wir auf das Thema
eingehen?
Und zwar das hier
unten.
Ich habe es extra unter das Rust-Thema gepackt.
Ich habe die perfekte Überleitung.
Achso, dann
wollen wir mit dem Rust-Thema
anfangen? Gern.
Okay.
Jetzt irgendwie einen Übergang
finden, der sich gut schneiden lässt.
Ein Thema, was wir
noch auf der Liste haben.
Wir haben ja früher mal diese NPM-Fuck-Habs der Woche gehabt,
weil du dich erinnerst.
Wo wir bei weiteren traurigen Themen
sind, die diese Woche oder in der letzten
Woche passiert sind.
Wir hatten ja früher häufig mal NPM-Fuckups.
Und jetzt gibt es ein Rust-Fuckup.
Also es ist kein Rust-Fuckup.
Es gibt auch dazu noch ein Rust-Fuckup,
aber den wollen wir gar nicht thematisieren.
Man könnte das Thema auch Rust-Community-Drama der Woche nennen?
Das ist schön.
Das trifft es ganz gut.
Was ist denn passiert?
Eigentlich ist überhaupt nichts passiert.
Also eigentlich ist gar nichts passiert wirklich.
Aber es hat trotzdem niemanden daran gehindert, sich herrlich darüber in die Haare zu kriegen und auch wie Leute Diktatoren zu nennen.
Und zwar fing das damit an, dass auf der Library Serda ein Issue aufgemacht hat.
Das ist für sich nicht daran erinnert, dieses Serialization-Deserialization-Framework.
Ein Issue aufgemacht wurde und bei Serda handelt es sich um das Serialization-Deserialization-Framework in Rust.
es ist einfach
ein generischer Serializer, Deserializer
für beliebige Formate, für die man
Serializer schreiben kann
und dazu
gibt es
eine extra Library, die heißt
Serderderive
das macht es einem möglich, einfach an
Structs ranzuschreiben, du bist jetzt
deserialisierbar
oder deserialisierbar
das ist ein ganz schöner Zungenbrecher
das ist ein besonderer Podcast
deserialisierbar ist, glaube ich,
dann wird ein Spin-Off-Podcast
deserialisierpunktbar.
Ich habe tatsächlich noch nicht so viel mit Rust gemacht,
wie ich gerne machen würde, aber selbst ich habe schon
Serde benutzt. Sehr gut.
Zumindest benutzt Serde für diese Funktionalität
ein Rust-Sprachfeature, das da heißt
Proc-Makros. Das ist einfach eine andere Form von
Makro, die
vom Compiler zur
Compile Time geladen wird,
ist auch nur Rust-Code
und dieser Rust-Code bekommt
ein TokenStream
Rust-Syntax
und produziert ein TokenStream
Rust-Syntax, der dann an der Stelle
eingefügt wird, wo man das
Makro definiert.
Und dadurch, dass man diese
Prog-Makros vor dem Kompilieren ausführt,
muss man die Libraries, die diese Prog-Makros
vielleicht selber verwenden, auch erstmal
Das heißt, wenn du irgendwo diese Serda-Annodation in deinem Code verwendest, muss, wenn dein Code gebaut wird, erstmal Serda-derived gebaut werden, damit man das quasi als Compiler-Plugin nehmen kann, um deinen Code da durchzupfeifen.
Die Person, die Serda vornehmlich betreut, ist David Tolney. Den haben wir, glaube ich, auch früher schon mal erwähnt. Das ist, glaube ich, die Person mit den meisten Downloads im Rust-Ökosystem.
Also wenn man auf Crates.io geht und sich da in der mittleren Spalte anguckt,
Most Downloaded, dann ist glaube ich die Hälfte von diesen Crates, die da aufgezählt werden, von ihm.
Unter anderem die oberen beiden, Syn und Quote und weiter unten steht Cerde.
Und Proc Macro 2 ist auch von ihm.
Und IJota ist von ihm.
Ich glaube Auto CFG auch.
Also von dem ist wirklich, wirklich viel.
Das ist auch alles wirklich gutgeschriebenes Zeugs.
Und wenn ich jetzt meinen Code kompiliere, baue ich erstmal SYN, das ist ein Rust-Parser, der diesen Token-Stream parst, dann mir eine API anbietet, um daraus anderen Rust-Codes zu erzeugen oder darauf zu arbeiten.
und Quote ist dann so eine Art JSX oder TSX, wo ich Rust schreibe und dann an bestimmten Placeholdern reinpaste,
wie meine Variablen ausgefüllt werden soll.
Es macht wirklich Spaß damit, Makros zu bauen, aber die müssen halt auch erst kompiliert werden,
bevor dein Code kompiliert wird und das macht die Compile-Zeit länger.
Dieser David Tollner hat sich gedacht, ich mache die Compile-Zeit davon jetzt einfach besser
und hat
in einem
Fix-Update, man muss dazu sagen, die meisten
seiner Crates haben die Version 1.0.
irgendwas. Wenn der was veröffentlicht,
ändert der nie wieder die API davon.
Der bringt immer was raus, was ist Version 1.0
und danach zählt die
Fix-Version bis in die
Hunderte hoch.
Cool, eigentlich ist das Version hier auch.
Der hat in
Version
1.0.
von Cerde
von Cerde-Derive eingeführt,
dass diese Prog-Makros, die deinen Code
parsen und anderen Rust-Code ausspucken,
einfach als vorkompilierte
Binarys runtergeladen werden.
Das heißt, er hat
die in der CI gebaut und
dann werden sie für deine Plattform,
werden Binarys für deine Plattform runtergeladen,
die parsen deinen Code, produzieren
anderen Code raus und es
ging marginal schneller damit,
Sachen zu kompilieren.
Dann gab es einige Wochen später auf dem Serda-Repo ein Issue
Using Serda-Derive without pre-compiled binary
Wo jemand, der eine Linux-Distribution maintaint
Ich glaube in dem Fall Fedora, der packagt Pakete für Fedora
Und hat aufgezählt
I'm working on packaging Serda for Fedora Linux
And I noticed that the recent versions of Serda-Derive ship pre-compiled binaries now
This is problematic for us, since we cannot, under no circumstances, with very few exceptions for firmware and the like, redistribute pre-compiled binaries.
Man hat halt nachgefragt, könnte man die pre-compiled binaries vielleicht wieder rausnehmen.
Ging ein gewisser Thread los, sehr viele Leute haben darauf diskutiert und nach einer Weile wurde der einfach wieder zugemacht.
Und dann ging ein halber Shitstorm los.
Der David Tollney hatte noch geschrieben, ja, es geht halt leider nicht anders.
Wäre schön, wenn mal jemand ein RFC schreiben würde, wie man das im Compiler oder in Cargo vielleicht schöner regeln kann.
Zum Beispiel ein RFC, wie man WebAssembly pre-compiled Prog-Macros verwalten könnte, gibt es aber nicht.
Aber das ändert doch auch nichts daran, dass du trotzdem pre-compiled Binary mitschippst.
Es gibt einen Unterschied und zwar das eine sind Binary's, die direkt auf deinem Betriebssystem als Binary's laufen und quasi dieselben Rechte haben wie eine normale Binary auf deinem System.
Und das andere sind WebAssembly-Binary's, die von einem WebAssembly-Interpreter oder von einer WebAssembly-Runtime ausgeführt werden und dementsprechend einigermaßen gesandboxed sind.
Also WebAssembly-Binary's sind Binary's, die Capabilities haben.
Du meinst so wie bei Dino, wenn du mit Dino was ausfährst,
wo du bestimmte Flags mitgeben musst, damit die überhaupt die Rechte haben.
Also du kannst...
Detailsystemzugriff, Netzwerkzugriff und so weiter.
Genau.
Okay.
Also eine WebAssembly Runtime ist eine Runtime, wo du per se keinerlei Rechte hast,
irgendwas zu machen und jedwede Capability, die deine Binary haben kann,
zum Beispiel auf Detailsystem oder Netzwerkzugreifen oder Environment-Variablen,
musst du die Runtime explizit mit reingeben.
Ich würde sagen, das machst du trotzdem nur marginal besser,
weil bestimmt brauchst du ja dann irgendwelche Rechte
und du kannst trotzdem nicht nachvollziehen, was das Ding tut.
Das Problem war doch hier auch,
dass es vor allem keine reproduzierbaren
Builds waren, oder?
Der Anspruch, dass du einen reproduzierbaren
Build haben möchtest, war, ich möchte
sehen, welchen Code ich habe,
und dazu kriege ich das raus.
Und wenn du das,
die Gegenargumente
waren, du siehst halt
genau, dass ich diesen Code hier gepackaged habe.
Aber ja,
das kannst du natürlich auch nicht 100% nachvollziehen,
ob das der Code ist, der gerade
welchen Code ich auf der Platte habe, wenn ich es zu Crates.io
hochlade. Das stimmt allerdings.
Zumindest wurde das irgendwann zugemacht,
dann wurde relativ
viel rumgezankt.
Und einer der anderen Maintainer
davon ist gerade im Urlaub, hat immer bloß so ein bisschen
beschwichtigend von der Seite mitgeschrieben und gesagt,
ja, ich gucke da mal mit drauf und vielleicht lässt sich auch was machen,
aber ich habe gerade nur mein Telefon.
Scheiße, wer im Urlaub bist, wenn da so ein Shitstorm losgeht.
So, der ursprüngliche
Typ, der das
Issue aufgemacht hat, hat dann
einen Fork von Cerda
Derive rausgebracht. Cerda
De-Blobbed.
Wo er quasi die aktuelle Version genommen hat
und genau diesen einen Change revertet hat.
Und
einige Leute haben sich auf Masso dann beschwert, dass sie
von dem Paket, von dem
Repo geblockt wurden,
weil sie auf irgendwas reagiert hatten,
von dem David Hollene.
Genau, weil sie aber eine Issue Reaction,
also so ein Thumbs-up-Emoji,
wo wir bei irgendeinem Kommentar gepostet haben,
Das klingt ja schon irgendwie ein bisschen, ich würde sagen übergriffig, aber...
Ja, und dann geht die gleiche Diskussion aber auch los mit, wenn jemand Open Source Code irgendwie zur Verfügung stellt, dann ist der nicht verpflichtet, auf deine Sachen einzugehen und wenn du es benutzt, dann without warranty und free of charge und es ist halt schließlich sein Projekt.
Das Problem ist, dass der so viel
so guten Code schreibt, dass das wirklich
überall mit drin ist. Das, wo ich
vor ein, zwei Folgen drüber geredet habe,
dass ich auf Arbeit verwende, um
Rust in den C++ Codebase einzubetten,
CXX, was dir
super coole Rust-to-C++-Bindings
generiert, ist auch von dem Typen.
Es gibt, glaube ich, kein modernes
Rust-Projekt, was nicht irgendwo Serda mit drin hat
in der Dependency-Liste.
Andere Leute haben gesagt, Serda
auch Shortcomings, vielleicht sollten wir mal über eine Alternative
nachdenken, aber
zum Schluss ist es, finde
ich, eigentlich recht
okay aufgelöst worden.
Nach einigen Tagen hatte dann
dieser David Tollney auf dem
Serde-Projekt Version
1.0.184
rausgebracht,
wo er die Binary
Prog-Makros wieder rausgenommen hat.
Das heißt, aktuelle
Releases haben keine Binary
keine Binarys mehr drin.
Also hat er sich quasi überzeugen lassen, dass das
noch nicht... Ich glaube, er hatte sich
er ist halt nicht hingegangen und hat gesagt
ja, ihr habt recht, ich mach das jetzt.
Sondern er hat einfach erstmal gesagt, er hat
erstmal nichts gesagt
und geschrieben, was er gerne hätte
und weshalb er das gemacht hat
und kein Commitment gemacht, irgendwas zu
verändern. Und dann, paar
Tage später tauchte dann in dem
Internal, also
es gibt auf User
es gibt zwei
Discourses auf
Rustlang.org, das für Users und das
Internal für, wo es um die Sprache geht.
Das ist nicht Internal, aber es ist eher so Meta.
Und da hat er einen,
was habe ich hier verlinkt? Also wo es um die Sprache geht?
Wo es um die Sprache selber geht.
Da hat er
veröffentlicht
einen Pre-RFC Setbox
Deterministic Reproducible
Efficient WESM
Compilation of
Proc Macros. Genau das, was er
Und witzigerweise hatte er so ein Projekt schon mal, das hieß WATT.
Das war ein WebAssembly-Proc-Makros vorkompiliert.
Warum er das nicht für Serde bereits benutzt war, ist mir nicht klar.
Es kann sein, dass es da in irgendwelchen Cargo-Features gemangelt hat.
Zumindest ist halt relativ viel rumgestritten worden.
Und zum Schluss hat der Typ das wieder zurückgerollt.
Und gleichzeitig selber diesen relativ umfangreichen Early-RFC geschrieben,
über den jetzt wahrscheinlich noch ein Weilchen diskutiert wird,
ob der zu dem RFC wird.
Ich habe mir die Diskussion nicht weiter durchgelesen.
Jetzt ist es quasi wieder wie vorher.
Allerdings sind nebenbei auch noch so andere Sachen rausgekommen.
Es gibt Leute, die meinten, der nimmt Cargo-Hostage.
Kann man so auch ausgeben.
weil er möchte da ein Feature drin haben,
deswegen hat er diese Binary-Geschichte
gemacht, um irgendwie
Druck zu erzeugen oder sowas. Keine Ahnung,
ob da was dran ist. Dann haben sich
prominente Leute
in der Rust-Community auf Twitter gegenseitig
geblockt, weil sie irgendwie sich gestritten
haben. Dann kam noch
raus, ja, der David Toyman, der hat übrigens
auch noch bei Palantir gearbeitet,
eine ganze Weile lang.
Es ist sehr
guter, prominenter und weit
der Rust-Code von Leuten, die bei Palantir
arbeiten. Ist so.
Bei Palantir arbeiten leider sehr schlaue Leute,
die guten Code schreiben.
Er hat wahrscheinlich sehr gut dafür entlohnt.
Wahrscheinlich. Jetzt arbeitet
David Tolleney bei Google.
Ist das besser? Ich weiß es nicht.
Wahrscheinlich ist es
nicht ganz... Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, Palantir ist gut.
Google ist jetzt nicht die
Firma, die ich als super gut
empfinden würde, aber
ich denke,
Bars pretty high, um schlechter zu sein,
ist Palantir in der Hinsicht.
Also von Palantir sind halt auch so
echt ganz triviale
Entwicklungstools.
Wir haben lange Zeit für TypeScript
TSLint verwendet,
bevor ESLint TypeScript gekonnt hat,
haben wir TSLint verwendet.
Und irgendwann sagte einer meiner Kollegen,
ja, ich weiß nicht, ob wir das weiterverwenden wollen,
das ist von Palantir.
Und ich dachte mir, was zum Geil ist Palantir?
Ich kenne die Firma nicht.
Ja, andererseits glaube ich, das ist halt so ein Ding, dass bei solchen Firmen und Organisationen halt auch Sachen hinten rausfallen, die nicht zwangsläufig schlecht sind, nur weil sie von dieser Organisation kommen. Ich glaube, die, ich hoffe, ich vertue mich da jetzt nicht, aber ich glaube, die NSA beispielsweise hat auch signifikant zum Tor-Projekt beigetragen.
Die wollten halt auch eine Möglichkeit haben, Kontakte zu schützen oder Agenten zu schützen.
Also man kann bei amerikanischen Geheimdiensten sehr viel vorhalten,
aber sie haben tatsächlich ein relativ gut funktionierendes Programm,
um so Security-Software zu unterstützen.
Ja.
So, das war zumindest diese Geschichte.
Und ich hatte irgendwann mal aufgezählt, ich hatte hier auch mit aufgeschrieben, was von dem David Tollney wirklich ist. Und zwar CXX, womit man, was übrigens, da gibt es eine Google-Variante, Google CXX, womit die zum Beispiel wahrscheinlich in Chrome Rust-Code einbauen, weil Chrome mittlerweile auch relativ viel Rust-Code enthält.
Nice. Ich glaube,
das könnte, ist sehr wahrscheinlich, dass
der Typ da sehr stark daran beteiligt
ist.
So Convenience-Crates wie
Anyhow und This Error, was Error-Handling
in Rust wesentlich einfacher macht.
Dann so krasse Sachen wie Async-Trade.
Es ist in Rust nicht möglich,
asynchrone, oder bislang nicht,
es ist auf eine sounde Art und Weise
möglich, asynchrone Methoden
in Trades zu definieren.
Es sei denn, du verwendest Async-Trade, dann schreibst du dieses
Makro-Async-Trade oben drüber und dann geht's.
Cool.
Mit gewissen
Performance-Einschränkungen, aber...
Was macht das unmöglich, dass du einen Traitor definierst?
Kann man das ganz grob zusammenfassen?
So dass ich es verstehe?
Ich habe es nicht verstanden selber.
Es geht darum, dass du
bei asynchronen
Methoden, bei asynchronen
Aufrufen noch Lifetimes
mitspielen.
Und die kannst du
bei Trades nicht von vornherein alle
mit definieren oder beschreiben.
Es gibt jetzt ein Nightly-Feature,
asynchrone Trade-Funktionen
zu haben, aber
das haben sie in dem Blogpost erwähnt,
mit gewissen Einschränkungen.
Ich glaube, das Async-Trade macht einfach überall
einen Heap-Pointer drumherum.
Es boxt dir deine Features und dann legen sie
auf den Heap und das macht alles ein bisschen einfacher.
Das ist natürlich gut nachvollziehbar.
Ich weiß, wenn Bidded-Programmierer
bekommen mal Angst, wenn jemand sagt, es macht über einen Heap-Pointer
draus.
Deswegen verwendest du es wahrscheinlich.
Na klar, ich meine,
du arbeitest auf einer ganz anderen Ebene.
Ich habe keinen Heap.
Du bist Embedded-Programmierer?
Ich mache tatsächlich.
Ich finde das sehr interessant,
als ihr vorhin von Web-Frameworks geredet habt.
Ich bin, glaube ich,
so weit weg von User-Software,
wie man von User-Software weg sein kann,
ohne
Sachen von Hand aufzulöten.
Also
möchtest du uns davon erzählen, Johannes?
Tatsächlich gibt es ein super
interessantes Projekt, aber das
Press-Release ist noch nicht durch, deswegen kann ich noch
nichts darüber erzählen.
Aber wir haben
sehr viele fancy Dinge getan und
ich habe sehr viel über ARM64
Assembly gelernt.
Es gibt aber ein anderes
Projekt, über das ich reden kann.
Und zwar gibt es ein
Es gibt ein Protokoll, das heißt Security Protocol and Data Model.
Das ist quasi ein Remote Authentication Protokoll für SPADM.
Und das ist quasi, wenn dein Trusted Execution Environment in deiner Grafikkarte mit deinem Trusted Execution Environment deine CPU reden will und zwar so, dass niemand dazwischen Dinge tun kann.
Und keine Ahnung, für Sachen wie Content Protection und solchen Spaß.
Aber auch beispielsweise Secure Cloud Computing.
Wenn du nicht möchtest, also beispielsweise möchtest du halt Grafikkarten in deiner Cloud anbieten,
aber du weißt, dass deine Kunden auf keinen Fall möchten, dass du die Daten sehen kannst,
dann können sich die Kunden quasi direkt mit der Grafikkarte identifizieren.
Das geht ein bisschen wie Intel SGX Extensions.
Ja, es geht in die Richtung und SPDM wurde unter anderem auch von Intel und anderen großen Firmen entwickelt.
Und EdaCore hat ein Projekt gemacht, in dem Rekordflux verwendet wurde, um dieses Protokoll für NVIDIA zu spezifizieren.
Ich muss glaube ich jetzt ein bisschen ausholen.
Rekordflux ist ein Code-Generator, der Binär-Protokoll-Parser anhand einer Spezifikation generiert.
Übrigens, wenn euch das zu hart ist, wir haben Chapter Marks und wir reden später noch über andere Themen.
Wir können jetzt in eure Podcasting-App in eure Chapters reinschauen und vielleicht einfach zum nächsten Chapter springen.
Ich bin so ehrlich, muss ich mit euch sein. Bitte red weiter.
Und man schreibt halt eine Spezifikation für sein Binärprotokoll auf, beispielsweise TLS oder IP.
Und ganz viele Sicherheitslücken im Internet basieren ja darauf, dass irgendwer dafür von Hand ein Parser in C aufgeschrieben hat.
Und der Parser ist unsicher und dann hat man schon seine Sicherheitslücke.
Quasi jedes CV ist gefühlt sowas.
Ja, im Prinzip fast alle remote ausnutzbaren Sicherheitslücken basierend darauf.
Und unsere Idee ist es halt, es gibt halt die Programmiersprache Spark, über die ich ja letztes Mal schon geredet habe.
Und in der kann man beweisbare Software schreiben und die dann auch beweisen.
Und das ist halt aber immer noch relativ komplex und sehr, sehr arbeitsaufwendig.
Und wir haben hier angefangen mit Componolite und jetzt mit Edacore Recordflux entwickelt,
was ein Code-Generator ist, der anhand dieser Spezifikationen Spark-Code generiert
und man bekommt quasi einen in Spark geschriebenen Protokoll-Parser und der beweist.
Krass.
Also den kann man noch in seinen Beweiser reintun und der Beweiser läuft da drüber und der beweist.
Das heißt, man hat eine...
Der beweist heißt, so viel ist kopiliert, es ist abgehakt, oder?
Naja, im Prinzip erfindet er keine Fehler bis zu einem gewissen Level.
Also beispielsweise können wir beweisen, dass in unserem Protokoll-Parser keine Laufzeitfehler drin sind.
Und da sind halt keine Buffer-Overflows drin und keine Integer-Overflows.
Und zu gewissen Graden können wir auch beweisen, dass sich der generierte Code der Spezifikation entsprechend verhält.
Und auch die Spezifikation selbst wird halt formal überprüft auf bestimmte Bedingungen,
beispielsweise, dass keine Logikfehler in der Nachricht drin sind, dass alle Felder erreichbar sind,
dass keine Lücken enthalten sind, dass keine Felder sich überlappen, zumindest nicht implizit.
Und solche Dinge, die halt oft dazu führen, dass jemand einen korrekten Parser gebaut hat,
aber das Protokoll halt auch korrekt implementiert
und das Protokoll ist aber kaputt
und dann
geht der Parser kaputt. Ich glaube, letztens gab es
sowas bei Bluetooth.
Wenn man Bluetooth hundertprozentig korrekt
implementiert, dann kann man
einen Downgrade-Angriff fahren,
dass Bluetooth einen 8-Bit-Schlüssel verwendet.
Also quasi
ein Fehler in der Spec, also kein Fehler,
aber eine Lücke in der Spec
mit drin, die dir ermöglicht.
Ja.
Diese Angriffe sind häufig möglich, wenn zwei Endpunkte
über ein Kryptoverfahren
negotiaten.
Und man einfach sagt, ich kann nur das ganz Schlechte.
Genau.
Deswegen ist zum Beispiel ein TLS
so eine Negotiation, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr drin.
Und das ganz Schlechte bei Bluetooth
ist halt so schlecht, dass kann man im Zweifel
alle Schlüssel von Hand aufschreiben.
Man braucht
theoretisch nicht mal einen Computer dafür.
Acht Bits
sind nicht viele Bits.
256 verschiedene Schlüssel.
ist jetzt nicht so krass schwer zu knacken.
Aber auf jeden Fall haben wir dieses Protokoll für NVIDIA spezifiziert
und wir haben den Code generiert
und es sind ungefähr 200.000 Zeilen Quellcode rausgekommen,
was jetzt enorm viel klingt.
Und NVIDIA kam zu uns und hat gemeint,
ja, könnt ihr das irgendwie in 30 Kilo Byte reinpacken?
Ja.
Und ich habe dann so angefangen, rumzuoptimieren
und dann habe ich halt auch bei unseren Compiler-Experten nachgefragt
und die haben erstmal die Hände über den Kopf zusammengeschlagen,
als sie gemeint haben, wie viel Code bist du, Hami?
So 25 Kilobyte.
Und sie meinten dann so, wie viel Quellcode hast du?
Und ich so, 140.000 Zeilen.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht ohne weiteres möglich.
Aber am Ende ist es halt so, dass da halt 3.000,
ich habe jetzt gerade im Papers gefunden, 135.000 Zeilen Code sind das.
Und das sind 3.000 Zeilen tatsächlicher Code, der kompiliert wird
und die anderen 132.000 Zeilen Codes sind Beweise.
Aha, okay.
Und man kann die kompilieren und man kann die dann auch ausführen zum Testen.
Dann wird das ein sehr, sehr dickes Binary.
Ja, aber das brauchst du halt nur zur Verifikation, oder?
Genau. Und in dem Fall wäre es Validierung.
Okay, fair.
Und genau, das Target war dann quasi ein RISC-V 64-Target.
Und wir haben da eine 35-KB-Bibliothek dafür gebaut.
Und wir haben angefangen und wir sind da relativ naiv drangegangen, weil der generierte Code war jetzt nicht super effizient.
Wir hatten bis jetzt noch die Use Case, den da wirklich zu optimieren.
Und dann haben wir am Anfang so ein Drittel der Features eingebaut und es war dann so bei 170 Kilobyten.
Ich habe schon ein bisschen gedacht, das wird eng.
Und da müssen ja noch Features rein.
Und es war sehr viel, ich habe sehr viel gelernt.
Und es war quasi immer ein Schritt vorwärts,
indem wir haben Optimierungen in den Code-Generator eingebaut,
wir haben Shortcuts eingebaut.
Die Optimierungen und Shortcuts im Code-Generator sind ziemlich ähnlich zu denen,
die man üblicherweise in einen Compiler einbauen würde.
Das Konzept ist im Prinzip das gleiche.
Man wirft Code rein, es kommt Code raus
und am Ende auch das Binary ist ja irgendwie Code,
den halt der Prozessor direkt lesen kann.
Und das ging dann, das sind so die einen Sachen und die anderen Sachen,
irgendwann wusste ich, hatten wir dann keine guten, also am Anfang hat man
viele Low-Hanging-Fruits, da sieht man, okay, das sind ganz viele Funktionen, die machen alle das Gleiche, da kann man
rausfaktorieren und solche Sachen. Und irgendwann kommt man an den Punkt, da weiß man dann nicht mehr so genau,
was da jetzt passiert. Und dann habe ich angefangen, den Quercode
mir an, also das Object Dump, also das Dekompilat mir anzuschauen.
Er hat es gesagt, ich weiß nicht.
Innerlich zusammengezuckt.
Und ich habe dann eine Excel-Tabelle gemacht
und jede Zeit der Quellcode auf so und so viel,
auf eine Speicheradresse im kompilierten Code gemappt,
um rauszufinden, wo die ganzen Dinge herkommen,
die da Größe und Speicherplatz verbrauchen.
Handcrafted Artisanal Spinarys hier, die dann mal rauskommen.
Es sind da interessante Sachen rausgefallen.
Ich meine, wir haben sehr viel am Compiler rumgetunt.
Wir haben auch den einen oder anderen Compiler.
Das müsste ja fast eigentlich ein Feature sein,
was ja auch dein Compiler sagen könnte, wo ist es fett, oder?
Es ist schwierig.
Ich meine, die normalen Compiler-Optimierungen für Größe sind halt schon sehr gut,
weil viele Leute dieses gleiche Problem haben.
Aber wir haben halt auch einen Code-Generator
und der handgeschriebene Code ist grundsätzlich effizienter
und besser gepackt als generierter Code,
weil du kannst halt zum Zeitpunkt, zu dem du generierst,
weißt du nicht immer, auf was du optimierst.
Und an einigen Stellen habe ich halt so Pattern identifizieren können,
wo ich ganz stolz auf mich war, dass ich intelligenter war als der Compiler,
weil ich gesagt habe, diese Funktion musst du alle inline,
auch wenn die so aussehen, als würde es sich nicht lohnen.
Aber wenn man den Compiler zwingt, dass sie alle geinlined werden,
dann erkennt der Compiler auf einmal das Pattern wieder
und dann kann er daraus eine super kurze Expression machen.
Und normalerweise inlinen wir dann nur noch Sachen,
die entweder nur einmal verwendet werden
oder wo die Funktion selbst kleiner ist als der Call auf die Funktion.
Und das trifft nicht auf so viele Sachen zu.
Und wie gesagt, ich habe sehr viel gelernt.
Und wir sind am Ende bei 35 Kilobyte herausgekommen.
Krass.
Es war ein langer Weg, es war ein schmerzhafter Weg.
Was war das Ziel nochmal, wo ihr hinwolltet?
Ich glaube, es waren so 30, 35 Kilobyte.
Wir sind ungefähr auch da rausgekommen, wo wir hinwollten.
was ich am Anfang, ich habe es mehrmals
zwischendurch angezweifelt, dass wir das jemals
erreichen, muss ich ehrlich zugeben
aber wir sind halt irgendwie dahin
gekommen und
es gibt sehr viele Dinge
auf die man da achten
kann und wo der Compiler
Dinge tut, die man nicht erwartet
aber die andere Erkenntnis war auch, dass
die Optimierung, die wir da gemacht haben
auf der nächsten Architektur unter Umständen
super optimal sind
je nach Anwendungsfall.
Und wenn man anfängt,
sich das Object Dump anzuschauen,
dann ist man an dem Punkt,
an dem alle Optimierungen,
die man da macht,
nur noch für die spezifische Architektur gelten,
weil andere Architekturen,
die haben andere Function Cores,
die haben bestimmt andere Eigenschaften,
da funktionieren andere Pattern besser,
weil die Instructions existieren
oder es funktionieren Pattern schlechter,
weil sie nicht existieren.
Das sind halt
die Aufgaben vom Compiler, das
da möglichst generisch zu halten, beziehungsweise dann
spezifisch auf die Architektur zuzuschneiden, wenn du weißt,
dass gewisse Sachen besser laufen.
Da frage ich mich zum Beispiel gerade, wie so ein LLVM-basierter Compiler
das macht, weil du machst normalerweise, erzeugst du eine
Intermediate Representation von deinem
Code, zum Beispiel bei LLVM, dieser
LLVM IR,
das ist so eine Art
Pseudo-Assembly, aber halt für eine
falsche Virtual-Maschine,
eine Low-Level-Virtual-Maschine.
Und darauf werden diese Optimization-Runs gemacht.
Und danach wird das dann erst zu plattformspezifischem Code gemacht.
Aber eigentlich könnte man es, wenn man sobald man weiß,
das ist zum Beispiel für x86 oder sowas,
könnte man es nochmal optimieren.
Es wird im Prinzip auch getan.
Also du hast Optimierung auf der IR.
Und bei der IR ist es so, es gibt da verschiedene Dinge.
Ist euer Compiler LLVM-basiert?
Wir haben einen LLVM-basierten Compiler.
Also die meisten unserer Compiler sind, also eigentlich fast alle unsere Compiler sind GCC-basiert, aber wir arbeiten aktuell an, es gibt ein LLVM Frontend für ADA.
Ich selber habe mir damit auch schon einen Compiler für eine Architektur gebaut, die bisher nicht auf ADA gut unterstützt wurde.
Nämlich für den ESP8266, da hat ja Espressif seine eigene extensive Architektur.
Und ich habe irgendwann durch Zufall gesehen, dass sie ein LLVM 14 Backend gebaut haben für ihre Architektur und ich musste das ausprobieren.
Ich habe in einer Compiler-Firma und ich habe unser Frontend genommen und es einfach mit dem Backend, was Extensor hat, kompiliert und zusammengebaut.
Am Ende hat es tatsächlich einen Compiler, der hat modernen ADACode kompiliert und es ist Extensor-Bitecode rausgefallen, den ich ausführen konnte.
In was für Geräten sind diese Chips dran?
In deinem üblichen ESP, also so kleine Wi-Fi-Sachen.
Wie dem Flipper?
Das Add-on dafür wäre ein ESP32, der läuft auch auf Extensor.
Nicht alle, die neuen laufen auf RISC-V, aber das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Aber auf jeden Fall, genau, und im Prinzip, was passiert,
die ER, auf der ER wird optimiert.
Es gibt auch immer wieder Diskussionen, wie die ER aussehen soll,
weil wenn du sie einfacher machst, ist es schwieriger, neue Frontends zu bauen,
weil du sehr viele komplexe Sprachfeatures auf sehr einfache ER-Features mappen musst.
Aber es ist sehr viel einfacher, Backends zu bauen,
weil du ja nur sehr einfache Features auf deine komplexe
Hardware-Architektur
maps und du kannst sie halt dann
komplexer machen, das macht es einfacher
Frontends zu bauen, weil du mehr
Dinge aus deiner Sprache ausdrücken kannst
aber du musst dann halt diese komplexen
Ausdrücke irgendwie auf deine Hardware-Architektur
bringen und
es ist ein Trade-off, am Ende
landet man irgendwo in der Mitte, wo der
Effort, eine neue
Sprache oder ein neues Backend
zu bauen, an einem Punkt ist
dass es für sowohl die Frontend-Menschen
als auch die Backend-Menschen akzeptabel ist.
Das ist ein ähnliches Trade-off
wie bei Prozessoren selber mit deinem
Reduced Instruction Set oder
Large Instruction Sets.
Im Prinzip ja.
Deswegen haben manche Compiler auch mehrere Levels an IRs.
Ich glaube, der RAS-Compiler hat ein
HIR und ein MIR
und danach kommt erst dann das LVMIR.
Ja.
Der RAS-Code wird erst zu einem
Pseudo-RAS kompiliert, wo keine
High-Level-Syntax mir hervorkommt.
Dafür gibt es da drin dann Go-To-Statements.
Der ADA-Compiler
funktioniert gar nicht so anders tatsächlich.
Es gibt...
ADA hat sowieso ein bisschen spezieller
Art und Weise, wie es kompiliert wird. Ich meine, es gibt
noch zwischendurch den sogenannten Binder,
der generiert Code
und mir ist da aufgefallen,
am Anfang, als ich mit ADA angefangen habe, war das
ein super anstrengendes Ding, weil du hast immer diesen Extra-Step
und weder in Make noch in C
noch in irgendeiner anderen Sprache hast du diesen Extra-Step
und der klebt da immer so an dir dran und das ist
super nervig, wenn man das nicht kennt.
Der Binder ist kein Linker.
Der Binder ist vor dem Compiler.
Der generiert halt
zur Bind-Time, sprich vor der Compile-Time
generiert der nochmal Code.
Also eine Art Pre-Processor.
Ja, nur in gut.
Aber dann habe ich so Sachen gesehen, beispielsweise
in Rust, wenn du willst eine...
Da hat man sowas auch, da gibt es
Prog-Macros.
Ja, aber der Beiner macht fanciere Sachen.
Beispielsweise, was du in Rust nicht machen kannst,
ist, du kannst eine statische Variable
nicht mit einer Funktion initialisieren.
Also, ja, mit Umwegen, aber grundsätzlich nicht.
Ich weiß, es gibt eine Create dafür.
Ich meine, ich habe den ganzen Spaß selber mal probiert.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht direkt in der Sprache drin.
Und in Ada gibt es was, das nennt sich Elaboration Time.
Okay, please elaborate.
Ja, und beispielsweise alle deine Variablen, die du quasi in ADN, das Package Level in C, wären es halt einfach globale Variablen.
Und die kannst du mit quasi beliebig komplexem Code initialisieren.
Und der Binder sorgt dafür, dass die Initialisierungsreihenfolge dieser Dinge korrekt ist.
Und der sagt dir auch, wenn es nicht geht.
Und der Binder generiert quasi eine Initialisierung für dein Programm,
die dafür sorgt, dass alle deine globalen Variablen so initialisiert werden,
dass es halt funktioniert und dass es nicht kaputt geht.
Ist das nicht einfach dasselbe, was bei C++ oder Rust Const Evaluation wäre?
Es ist halt nicht Const Evaluation.
Er generiert Code, der zur Laufzeit diese Variablen initialisiert.
Ah, okay.
Also es wird statisch
Code generiert, der dann zur Laufzeit statische Variablen
initialisiert.
Genau. Aber der Vorteil,
ich meine, das klingt jetzt erstmal irgendwie überflüssig,
aber der Vorteil ist, man kann,
gerade für Embedded ist das ultra hilfreich,
weil du kannst all dein Kram in statische Variablen
reinlegen, was halt deine
Speicherverwaltung massiv vereinfacht.
Und du kannst sie trotzdem mit beliebig
komplexem Code initialisieren und
damit arbeiten und der Binder sorgt dafür, dass du
nicht so Dinge hast wie in C++,
wo die Initialisierung, ich glaube, da gibt es auch irgendwie Static Initializers an irgendeinem Punkt,
aber im Prinzip sorgt der Binder dafür, dass all das korrekt initialisiert wird
und der schmeißt dir das auch in die Ohren, wenn du es nicht korrekt tust.
Und wenn man einmal an diesem Punkt ist und das verstanden hat,
ist der Binder ein super hilfreiches Tool und der generiert dann quasi den sogenannten Elaboration Code.
Der wird quasi vor dem eigentlichen Main-Programm ausgeführt.
und dann läuft dann mit dem Programm los,
das heißt all deine Variablen sind schon initialisiert.
Das ist schon ein Titel auch dafür,
der Elaboration Code.
Elaboration.
Und danach kommt der Compiler, der kompiliert dann
dann den Ada-Code und Byte-Code und dann kommt der linker
und ab da läuft halt alles wieder ganz normal.
Wo wir gerade bei Elaboration sind,
das ist ja schon ziemlich elaborate, was du gerade erzählst.
Wir haben aber eigentlich
zu dem Thema Ada,
da steht hier in den Shownotes was von
Ada Hijack?
Na, gehijackt habe ich das jetzt gerade schon.
Ach, das war das, okay.
Stark.
Abgefahren, cool.
Was sind denn die anderen Punkte, die du hier aufgerissen hast?
Genau, also ich habe hier das Ada Project Summary verlinkt.
Das ist das vom Anfang.
Da stehen die ganzen fancy Projekte drin.
Ich kann da mal ein bisschen daraus vorlesen,
für die, die keine Lust haben, dann später auf den Link zu klicken.
Ja, die Leute können, glaube ich, im Service-Fall auf den Link klicken.
Also hier ist eine unendlich lange Liste.
Air Traffic Management, Commercial Aviation.
Da sind diverse Airbus-Typen, diverse Boeing-Typen,
Railway Transportation, Commercial Rockets, Atlas, Ariane,
Communication, Navigation, Satellites and Receivers,
Scientific Space Vehicles, das ist unter anderem der European Space Agency Mars Express.
Also ich denke, da läuft schon was auf dem Mars.
Übrigens auch die Rosetta-Sonde, die bis zu einem Kometen geflogen ist.
Cool.
Es gibt erstaunlicherweise auch Desktop- und Web-Applications hier, was ich interessant finde.
Und, Adair, mein Kehr?
So Dinge wie TextCut,
Program for Drawing and Retouching,
Pictures in Lattisch.
Nicht das, was ich erwartet hätte,
um ehrlich zu sein.
Das muss definitiv verifizierbar korrekt sein.
Ja, und die längste Liste
ist ganz unten und das sind Military Applications.
Was halt auch einfach daherkommt,
dass das Department of Defense
am EDA
quasi gezielt entwickelt hat,
mit dem Ziel, eine Sprache zu haben,
die die ganzen Probleme von 10 nicht hat
die es erlaubt, sicheren Code zu schreiben,
wo man nicht mal aus Versehen,
weil man irgendwo ein halbes Zeichen vergessen hat,
statt einem Vergleich eine Zuweisung hat.
Und dann Dinge ganz obskur kaputt gehen,
weil die Explosionen trotzdem ausgewertet werden.
Ich meine, Marshall-Körper sind teuer,
die dürfen nicht abschließen.
Das ist der Punkt.
Auch alles andere, was so rumfährt,
ist teuer und sollte nicht runterfallen.
Ja, vor allem, dass das Runterfallen etwas destruktiv ist.
Ja.
Aber um zum eigentlichen Thema zu kommen,
Ich hatte mich letztens, oder ist auch schon wieder eine Weile her, ein bisschen intensiver mit Rust,
in dem Fall Rust für Embedded beschäftigt, und da habe ich halt das Embedded-Hull für Rust gefunden,
was im Prinzip versucht, die Treiber zu unifien, sodass jeder seinen Treiber gegen dieses Hardware-Abstraction-Layer baut.
Das hat gar nicht mit Hull 9000 zu tun?
Nein, das ist das Hardware-Abstraction-Layer, das heißt, wenn ich einen Treiber für ein Display habe,
aber den beispielsweise auf meinem Raspberry Pi verwenden möchte
oder auf meinem ESP32 verwenden möchte,
dann muss ich nicht für jede dieser Plattformen einen neuen Treiber
für das gleiche Display schreiben,
sondern ich kann meine Treiber für diese Plattform
gegen dieses Hardware-Abstraction-Layer bauen
und dann quasi direkt den Display-Treiber,
der auch gegen dieses Hardware-Abstraction-Layer gebaut ist, verwenden.
Das klingt richtig sinnvoll.
Mein erster Gedanke war, sowas brauchen wir auch in ADA.
Und dann habe ich mit einem meiner Kollegen geredet
und der meinte so, das haben wir schon in Ader,
das ist die Eder Drivers Library,
die ich ja auch verlinkt habe.
Und die Eder Drivers Library
ist so ein bisschen ein komplexeres Ding.
Da sind auch viele
Treiber schon drin, aber das hat auch ein Hardware Abstraction
Layer drin. Das klingt jetzt erstmal
ein bisschen kompliziert zu benutzen.
Aber dann kommt der andere Punkt,
die Eder Menschen haben selber gemerkt,
dass das Cargo ein geiles Tool ist
und wir wollten das auch.
Und deswegen ist irgendwann Aliyah entstanden.
Okay.
Und das ist quasi das, ich würde es als das Cargo für ADA bezeichnen.
Und das Crates.io mit, oder?
Also dass du quasi ein Package Repository hast.
Genau, es hat ein Package Repository, die Crates heißen.
Crates.
Okay, also es gibt jetzt Crates für ADA.
Genau.
Das hat aber nichts mit Rust zu tun.
Es hat nichts mit Rust zu tun.
Es ist im Prinzip das ADA-Äquivalent dafür.
und
mit 367
Crates. Die ADA-Community ist leider nicht sehr
groß, aber ich glaube, das ist trotzdem der
richtige Weg, einfach
um die wenigen ADA-Community
Members
zusammenzuführen, um quasi die Ressourcen,
die man zur Verfügung hat, auch sinnvoll
zu bündeln und sinnvoll
zu nutzen und man nicht jede
Bibliothek von Hand irgendwo raus
fummeln muss, wenn man die verwenden möchte.
Und in diesem
Alaya gibt es unter anderem die
Hull Crate, die das Hardware Abstraction
Layer bereitstellt. Ja, cool.
Ich arbeite
noch in meiner
knappen Freizeit
an einem Blogpost,
in dem ich das demonstrieren möchte,
mit einem Display
und verschiedenen Mikrocontrollern, die den
gleichen Displaytreiber auf verschiedenen
Hardware-Aktoren können. Ich dachte, als ich
die Überschrift gelesen habe,
ah, man kann jetzt also ADA-Code in
Crate in Rust
embedden. Der Punkt ist, das kann man
zu einem gewissen Teil auch, dafür habe ich
auch eine Lösung. Ah, okay.
Die habe ich tatsächlich selbst...
Also so fancy
ist es noch nicht, leider.
Aber die habe ich tatsächlich selbst gebaut
und zwar nennt sich das Projekt
GPR Rust. Wir haben den
Johannes nur eingeladen, damit er hier sein ganzes Projekt geplant hat.
Ja, natürlich. Was habt ihr denn gedacht?
Das nennt sich GPR Rust.
Und das ist tatsächlich eine Rust-Crate.
Aber
es ist eine Rust-Crate, die
Lass mich kurz den Link einfügen.
Es ist eine Rust-Grade, die es einem erlaubt,
verhältnismäßig einfach ADACode zu bauen und auch zu linken.
Und also der Use-Case ist quasi diese Rust-Grade eigentlich nur in einem Build-Script zu verwenden,
in einem Rust-Build-Script.
Und sie kann quasi...
Dass du zur Compile-Time-Ada-Code baust.
Genau, sie kann quasi, also sie nutzt, es gibt die GPR-Bibliothek.
Was ist GPR?
Das nennt sich Knud Project.
Das ist im Prinzip das Ader basiert auf Projekten.
Also es gibt quasi Projekte, mit denen du Ader baust.
Du kannst es auch von Hand mit jeder Datei einzeln, wie in C bauen, wenn du das unbedingt möchtest.
Also es ist ein Ader-Package einfach.
Ja, es ist irgendwo in der Mitte zwischen Package-Manager und Make.
Du brauchst es an vielen Stellen, weil durch den Binder hast du spezifische Abhängigkeiten zwischen deinen Dateien,
die das Ding halt auch mitmanage.
und das Ding kann halt, also das ist im Prinzip nur ein Binding auf die GPR-Implementierung in Ader
und das kann diese Projektdateien lesen, das heißt, wenn du eine Bibliothek in Ader hast,
kannst du sie mit sehr, sehr wenigen Zeilen Code in dein Rust-Build-Script einbinden
und GPR-Rust gibt dir direkt die richtigen Linker-Flags und die richtigen Include-Pfade für deinen Linker,
um dein Build-Tool einfach direkt zu sagen,
da sind die linker Flags, da liegt die Bibliothek,
da wurde sie hin kompiliert.
Jetzt kannst du sie einfach in dein Rust-Projekt mit reinlinken.
Und so kannst du halt deinen ADA-Code einfach in Rust einfügen
und dort benutzen.
Ich lese gerade zum ersten Mal ADA-Code in dem Zusammenhang.
Ich finde, ADA hat viele tolle Feet.
Ich finde sowieso, es gibt so viele Sachen,
die ich gerne aus Rust in ADA hätte.
Und an vielen Stellen ist auch einfach Rust zu benutzen einfacher, weil einfach mehr Software existiert.
Auf der anderen Seite, jedes Mal, wenn ich einen Treiber schreiben will, denke ich an Record Representation Clause, die es einem erlauben, bitgenau Structs, also in C heißt es Structs, in A heißt es Record, zu definieren, inklusive Lücken und Padding und allem drum und dran.
Und das ist einfach so hilfreich, wenn man einen Treiber schreiben will.
Ich glaube, sowas ähnliches benutzen wir aber in einer Library von uns schon in Rust.
Und das heißt...
Bitfield.
Da annotierst du in Rust mit...
Da annotierst du ein Struct mit einem Makro und dann mapst du das auf eine Binäre Repräsentation.
Ja, ein Ada ist halt ein Sprachfeature.
Wenn ihr Johannes mehr über
ADA reden hören wollt,
empfehle ich
Akronymisierbar Folge 25 von vor
fünf Jahren,
wo wir bereits all die Sachen,
die für diese Folge offenbar zwingend vorausgesetzt
sind, hoffentlich eingeführt
hatten.
Aber das ist eine
beachtliche Stange an coolen Projekten,
die du uns hier gezeigt hast.
Vielen Dank für diese Einführung.
Ich bin
jetzt komplett überfordert.
wollen wir hier eine Chapter Mark ersetzen und über was anderes reden.
Chapter Mark auf jeden Fall, ja.
Cool.
Aber eigentlich, also du hast jetzt viel erzählt,
aber wir sind dazu gekommen, tatsächlich Fragen zu stellen.
Also siehst du, dass das ADA-Code bereits in,
also ist das GPR-Rust schon so weit, dass du siehst,
dass ADA-Code in anderen Rust-Projekten verwendet wird?
Oder hast du irgendwie konkrete eigene Use Cases,
wo du existierenden Ader-Code in ein Rust-Crate embeddest?
Mein eigentlicher Use-Case dafür war,
ich habe immer so ein paar IoT-Projekte, die ich irgendwann mal bauen will
und die fangen immer damit an, dass auf der Plattform,
auf der ich das gerne machen möchte, Ader noch nicht supportet wird.
Und die laufen dann ungefähr so weit, bis ich genug gebaut habe,
dass Ader-Code draufläuft und dann ist das zu viel Anwendungssoftware,
weil da müsste ich ja ganz viele Bibliotheken schreiben,
die es in Ader alle noch nicht gibt.
Das erinnert mich gerade sehr an diesen XKCD von wegen Real Programmers Use,
vor allem, glaube ich, der Titeltext davon, Real Programmers,
that the environment conditions on creation of the universe in the way...
Johannes macht erst mal das.
Ja, das ist halt, ich meine, das ist, glaube ich, auch das, woran ich Spaß habe,
einfach mir eine neue Architektur nehmen,
wofür, keine Ahnung, bloß ein LFM-Backend existiert und kein ADA-Compiler
und dann fange ich halt damit an, mir meinen eigenen Compiler dafür zu basteln.
Ich kann mich damit aber sehr anfreunden.
Also ich habe auch einige Libraries veröffentlicht,
wo ich irgendeinen kleinen Itch scratchen wollte
und dann habe ich festgestellt,
oh, dafür ist irgendeine Bedingung noch nicht erfüllt
und dann habe ich die meiste Zeit da rein investiert,
die Bedingungen zu schaffen, siehe dieses Notification-Crate.
Und dann, als ich dieses Problem gelöst hatte,
hatte ich aber das Interesse an dem allgemeinen Projekt komplett verloren
und deswegen maintäne ich irgendwelche Libraries für Kleinigkeiten,
die ich dann nie zu Ende gemacht habe,
aber die Libraries dafür sind besser maintained.
Ja, GPR Rust ist exakt daraus geboren worden.
Ich habe mir überlegt, wenn ich irgendwann mal einen Chipsatz finde,
wo halt jetzt das ganze Bring-Up und der ganze Hardware-Support schon in Rust gebaut wurde
und ich will halt da aber, keine Ahnung, einen spezifischen Treiber in ADA verwenden,
dann will ich halt jetzt nicht anfangen müssen, jedes Mal irgendwie was von Hand in Cargo reinzubasteln,
sondern dann will ich halt das einfach in Bequem haben.
Und dann habe ich es gebaut und dann hatte ich es in Bequem und dann bin ich zum nächsten Projekt gegangen.
Du bist zu bequem und zu langweilig.
Da gibt es irgendeinen Witz.
Übernachten ein Ingenieur, ein Physiker und
eine Mathematiker im Hotel und
nachts bricht ein Feuer im Hotelzimmer aus.
Und ich weiß nicht, was der Physiker und der Ingenieur
machen, aber es ist dann so was
wie, wacht auf,
sieht den Feuerlöscher, löscht damit das
Feuer. Und zum Schluss
war der Mathematiker, wacht auf, sieht den Feuerlöscher,
denkt sich, ah, das Problem ist lösbar
und dreht sich um den Schliff.
Das ist so ein gewisses, ja, meine Projekte laufen manchmal tatsächlich so ein bisschen so absurd. Ich sehe das, ich denke mir, was man da für coole Sachen bauen könnte und ich baue das so weit, bis es halt geht. Und weiß ich nicht, dann finde ich das nächste Projekt, von dem ich mir denke, was man so für coole Sachen damit machen könnte, wenn eine Ader drauf liefe.
Aktuell bin ich ein bisschen dabei für den ESP32C3, was ein RISC-V-Chipset von Espressif ist,
eine ein bisschen umfangreichere ADA-Bibliothek mit dem Hardware-Bstraction-Layer zu bauen.
Beziehungsweise dann nicht mehr nur für diesen Chipset, sondern Espressif hat ja das ESP-IDF,
was im Prinzip deren Development Kit dafür ist.
Und das bietet quasi vollständige APIs an für Wi-Fi und alles andere.
Aber halt nicht für ADA.
Genau, nicht für ADA und was ich im Prinzip baue ist, dass eine LiarCrate, wo das Bildsystem so angepasst ist, dass es automatisch dieses Development Kit einbindet, automatisch die richtigen CMake-Dinge generiert und dann baut es automatisch deine ADA-Anwendung komplett und dann generiert es das richtige CMake und ruft dann dieses ESP-IDL.
auf und das
ruft dann CMake auf und das CMake
findet dann deine in ADA gebaute
Bibliothek und linkt sie korrekt
in deine Anwendung rein und dann läuft sie halt auf deinem
Espressive-Chip-Satz.
Ich muss sagen, ich weiß nicht, was ich davon halten soll, dass das
in Alia auch Crate
heißt. Also ich meine, überall heißt es
Library und Library ist
genauso eine sinnlose Metapher, die
sich überhaupt nicht übertragen lässt.
Und bei Rust hieß es, wir machen jetzt
einen Bundler
und der Typ, der den Cargo-Bundler
der Typ, der das gebaut hat, ist
ich glaube, Yahuda Katz gewesen.
Der hatte vorher für
Rubinen
diesen Bundler gebaut.
Und da denkt man sich natürlich irgendeine
Metapher aus. Und bei uns heißt das so und so.
Also heißen die Pakete so und so. Und bei Rust
hieß das Projekt Cargo. Also es heißt
jede Library Crate.
Ich mag, dass das alle so ein
Schema haben. Und bei Aliyah
heißt das jetzt auch Crate. Und irgendwie
das ist doch der Name von den Rust-Paketen.
Ja, ich glaube,
bis Alaya hat es noch für einen alten Namen gereicht
und nachher einfach keine Lust mehr.
Ich ändere Namen für die gleichen Sachen auszudenken.
Und wir wussten alle, wo es hergeklaut ist.
Ich finde es ein bisschen schlimm,
dass Alaya für Ada Library Repository steht,
aber man das nicht Libraries dann.
Warum heißt es nicht A Crayray oder so?
Ich meine, es ist zumindest konsistent damit,
dass man, wenn man nach Ada sucht,
nicht das findet, was man haben will, weil
man meistens die American Disabilities Association
findet.
Oder eine komische Kryptowährung,
die aus irgendwelchen Gründen auch ADA heißt.
Es sind halt
einfach irgendwann für die ganzen Kryptowährungen
die Namen auch knapp geworden.
Ich bin immer nach der Meinung, man sollte eine Metakryptowährung
generieren.
Die hieß Libra.
Nein, wo quasi
jede Einheit der Kryptowährung ist.
Eine neue Kryptowährung.
Sehr schön.
Du kannst halt irgendwie so eine Meter
Kryptowährung, hast halt Bitcoin und dann die nächste ist,
keine Ahnung, Ethereum.
Und wer mehr Kryptowährungen
hat, der hat halt mehr Geld.
Kannst du auch dynamisch erzeugen.
Dann hast du, wie hieß das, NFCs?
NFTs?
NFTs und dann bist du der Besitzer
von Ethereum, von ganz Ethereum.
Das hat nie im Leben,
weil das gerade das erste Mal, dass diese Idee aufkam.
Das 100% hat die schon jemand
gemintet. Es gibt bereits jemanden,
der Ethereum besitzt und der ist
sich ziemlich sicher, dass ihm das niemand wegnehmen kann.
Letztens wurde doch irgend so ein Krypto-Dings
gehackt und dann hat jemand die ganzen
FT's runtergeladen und dann wurde
auf dem Krypto-Ding gelöscht
und dann hat irgendwer drunter geschrieben,
dass sie doch nicht so non-fungible
sind, wie man dachte.
Wir verlinken an dieser Stelle mal Web3 is going great.
Eine fantastische Webseite
immer und immer wieder.
Aber gut, soviel zum Thema Ader.
Wir wollten, glaube ich, vor 5 Minuten schon mal ein bisschen das Thema wechseln,
weil es wirklich sehr tief reingeggen.
Lass uns doch mal über was anderes reden.
Schönen Computer hast du da, Johannes.
Ja, ich finde den auch sehr, sehr toll.
Was ist das für ein Computer?
Der hat so ein KDE-esches Logo hinten drauf.
Ist das ein KDE-Computer?
Tatsächlich gibt es KDE-Computer, aber ich habe keinen.
What?
Ja, es gibt das KDE Slimbook.
Das hat dann so ein richtiges KDE-Logo hinten drauf.
Aber das hier ist so eine Art Zahnrad,
aber ein bisschen ein abgewetzteres.
Also wenn das ein Fahrradritzel wäre, würde ich es wechseln, würde ich sagen.
Ja, das ist...
Das sieht nicht mehr so gesund aus, stimmt.
Ich meine, das ist gar nicht so weit weg, weil das ist ein Laptop, der sehr lange halten soll.
Was ist das denn jetzt für eine Sache?
Es ist ein Framework-Laptop.
Du hast tatsächlich ein Framework-Laptop gekriegt?
Ja, ich habe ein Framework-Laptop.
Ich war mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher, ob es die richtige Idee ist, einen zu kaufen.
Ich meine, das Fairphone ist auch so eine Sache.
Ich meine, das Fairphone macht auch vieles richtig.
Und es gibt trotzdem viele andere Projekte, die ähnliche Sachen versucht haben, aber an den falschen Stellen die Kompromisse gemacht haben und einfach bei sehr, sehr unbenutzbaren Geräten rausgekommen sind.
Und ich meine, ich habe ein Librem 5 zu Hause.
Das ist das KDE-Handy, oder?
Nein, das ist das Telefon von Purism und deren Ziel ist, zu 100% freie Laptops herzustellen, inklusive freier Firmware für alle Komponenten.
Und bei Telefonen ist das Problem, dass der Markt sehr viel closer ist als bei Laptops.
Ich hätte sowas gerne auch, aber dann stellt man fest, dass das meiste, was man machen möchte, darauf dann leider nicht funktioniert.
Es geht halt nichts darauf.
Es geht halt ehrlich gesagt, ich wollte letztens flaschen, um darauf KDE Mobile zu testen.
Selbst das Flaschen geht nicht richtig und ich kann es nicht flaschen.
Also es ist nicht hart an der Grenze zur Unbenutzbarkeit, es ist unbenutzbar.
Der Akku hält auch irgendwie nur vier Stunden.
Und man konnte halt keine richtigen Mobile-Chips verbauen, weil die halt alle closed-toes sind.
Also hat man irgendwelche IoT-Chips verwendet, aber die sind halt einfach scheiße, wenn man Mobiltelefone bauen will.
Weil es hat einen Grund, dass es da verschiedene Sachen gibt.
Aber zurück zu den Dingen, die funktionieren.
Ich hatte ein bisschen diese ähnlichen Bedenken beim Framework-Laptop, aber tatsächlich ist es ein sehr geiles Gerät und es hat eine sehr hohe Qualität.
Was ist das Konzept der E-Tab?
Genau, also wir lassen uns mal darauf achten, dass wir möglichst nicht unbedingt eine Werbeveranstaltung draus machen.
Wir haben so viel über Macs in letzter Zeit gesprochen,
deswegen hat ja Johannes gesagt,
ich stand vor kurzem
tatsächlich sehr selber vor dieser Entscheidung,
ich möchte mir mal wieder einen neuen Laptop kaufen
und früher haben alle Thinkpads gehabt,
weil Thinkpads cool sind, aber
Thinkpads sind auch immer noch irgendwie
cool, aber irgendwie
das muss doch irgendwie
noch was weiteres geben und
jetzt gibt's
diese neuen
MacBooks und die haben
diese neuen coolen Apple Silicon
drin, aber man kann daran absolut
nichts selber reparieren oder austauschen.
Und was würde
ich nehmen, wenn ich irgendwie Teile an meinem
Computer selber reparieren oder austauschen
würde?
Ein Framework. Also das
ganze Konzept dahinter ist quasi ein Laptop,
der reparierbar ist und der
auch langlebig ist und bei dem man tatsächlich
auch irgendwann sagen kann,
mein Mainboard oder meine CPU ist mir zu
schwach und ich möchte eine CPU, aber
mein Display funktioniert ja noch und mein Akku funktioniert
noch, meine Tastatur funktioniert ja noch und das ist ja
das Elektroschrott und bei den meisten Laptops, wenn die CPU zu alt ist und der Arbeitsspeicher zu wenig,
mittlerweile ist der ja auch aufgelötet, dann wirft man halt den Laptop weg und dann fliegt halt alles weg,
obwohl ganz viele Komponenten ja noch einwandfrei funktionieren.
Und der Framework ist im Prinzip das Gegenkonzept dazu.
Das heißt, ich kann alle Teile austauschen, ich kann mir auch einfach ein neues Displaypanel kaufen, was matt ist.
Damals, als ich meinen gekauft habe, gab es leider noch keine matten Displays.
Aber es gibt Mathe-Displays, das heißt, ich könnte mir ein Mathe-Display kaufen, wenn ich das wollte.
Und oft ist bei solchen Geräten, und das war zum Teil auch beim Fairphone 3, das Versprechen, dass man dann irgendwann upgraden kann.
Und beim Fairphone 3 kam dann irgendwann das Fairphone 3 Plus und dann kommen irgendwie so drei Teile upgraden, aber so richtig Upgrade-Pfade gibt es dann nicht, außer ich kaufe mir halt irgendwann ein Fairphone 4.
Beim Framework ist es tatsächlich anders.
Es ist mittlerweile die vierte Generation an Mainboards rausgekommen.
Und sie fingen, oder es ist vielleicht auch die dreieinhalbte Generation.
Also es fingen, die ersten Mainboards kamen quasi mit einem i5 oder i7 Intel 11. Generation.
Ich habe jetzt einen 12. Generation.
Und da war auch schon mein Gedanke, eigentlich wollte ich lieber einen AMD-Laptop haben,
weil AMD halt aktuell cooler ist.
Und tatsächlich, man kann jetzt das gleiche Framework mit dem gleichen Body und im Prinzip den gleichen Teilen mit einem AMD-Mainboard bestellen.
Oder man bestellt sich einfach nur das AMD-Mainboard und ich werfe mein Intel-Mainboard weg.
Was kannst du bei diesem Laptop alles austauschen?
Weil das Mainboard ist ja bei modernen CPUs, gehen die Dinger ja Richtung System oder Chip.
Das heißt, du kannst nicht das Mainboard auseinandersetzen.
Das Mainboard ist schon noch am Stück, oder?
Ja, das ist, glaube ich,
das ist halt auch der Kompromiss, der gemacht wurde.
Das Mainboard ist noch am Stück, also Arbeitsspeicher.
Also du hast deinen kompletten Rechner
trotzdem, also der Computer,
abgesehen von der Peripherie
und dem Housing und dem
Display, Tastatur,
Gehäuse, Touchpad,
das
eigentliche,
man sagt immer, ich mag das Wort nicht, aber das
Logicboard ist trotzdem
am Stück. Ja, das ist einfach
dem geschuldet, es gibt keine
Das ist ja auch die Optimierung, also dadurch, dass
ich das alles auf einem Chip habe, ist es auch
wesentlich sparsamer und effizienter.
Ja, und es gibt auch aktuell, ich glaube, es gibt einfach keine
Laptop-CPUs mehr, die gesockelt sind.
Punkt. Also du kannst keine mehr
kaufen, niemand stellt mehr welche her, das heißt
du musst sie auflöten.
Es ist halt so viel nicht aufgelötet worden,
wie gegen bei modernen Computern,
sprich Arbeitsspeicher und SSD, kannst du halt
tauschen.
Aber ansonsten, ja, du musst
ja, wenn dein Mainboard defekt ist, musst du dein Mainboard
tauschen. Aber du kannst halt trotzdem den ganzen
anderen Kram behalten. Und auch der ganze andere Kram
kostet Ressourcen. Und auch der ganze andere Kram
ist eine Verbesserung, wenn du ihn nicht wegwerfen musst.
Ich hab ein 10 Jahre
altes ThinkPad zu Hause.
Und du kannst nichts mehr dran upgraden.
Das Display geht noch. Ich könnte mir
für irgendwie sehr viel Geld einen neuen Akku kaufen,
weil der Akku ist halt tot,
tot. Der geht gar nicht mehr.
Aber der Grund, warum ich mir einen Laptop
gekauft hab, ist auch, dass das ThinkPad ungefähr dreimal so dick
doppelt so schwer ist.
Das ist ja jetzt ein
den unsere Hörer nicht haben, aber das ist,
wenn du mir jetzt sagen würdest, das ist ein
modularer Laptop, würde ich dir das auf den ersten
Blick nicht glauben, weil es trotzdem
ein recht schlankes, kompaktes Gerät ist.
Und
ich habe mir ein paar Videos darüber
bei Linus Tech Tips angeguckt,
weil der, glaube ich, auch Investor von der Firma ist.
Viertel Millionen damit investiert, ja.
Genau, der hat dann irgendwann ein Video gemacht,
wo er dann ein zweites Mal darüber geredet hat,
dass er daran investiert hat und hat gesagt,
der Titel von dem Video war, I made a huge mistake
und dann war aber die Quintessenz, ich hätte noch viel
mehr Investitionen.
Das ist halt
YouTube-Video. Aber du kannst
halt auch zum Beispiel so Sachen machen wie
das Touchpad
rausnehmen und das irgendwie gegen
ein anderes Touchpad austauschen.
Du hast ja vorher
schon bei dem Logicboard,
so einem Mainboard,
was eine Komponente ist,
aber IO gehört ja typischerweise auch dazu.
Und das ist gerade bei dem Gerät
jetzt ein bisschen interessanter, weil die haben ja
als IO quasi eigentlich doch nur diese USB-C-Ports
intern dran. Und dann hast du
diese Expansion-Sorts an der Seite, wo du selber
wählen kannst, was für I.O. nach außen
du drin haben willst. Das heißt, du steckst so kleine
USB-C Adapter.
Eigentlich sind es USB-C Adapter.
Für Ethernet und für
USB-C.
Ja, also für Ethernet gibt es tatsächlich keinen.
Also die meisten für HDMI und
USB-A sind halt quasi so, dass sie
komplett reingehen. Es gibt welche für Ethernet.
Also Ethernet kann ich auch direkt bestellen auf der Webseite.
Ja, aber der Ethernet-Adapter, der verschwindet nicht im Gehäuse.
Ah, den muss man so leicht rausklappen.
Der schaut halt raus, einfach weil der Laptop viel zu dünn und schmal ist.
Also nicht dieses schmal alte Klappding, was du aufklappen kannst.
Nein, ich glaube, ich habe mir den mal angeschaut, der geht ein bisschen raus und ist halt höher.
Also das ist jetzt nicht die eleganteste Lösung, aber wenn du einen Internet-Adapter mithaben willst, dann kannst du das Ding halt mitnehmen.
Stimmt, der muss ja nicht die ganze Zeit drinstecken.
Das ist der Punkt, diesen Hotspot-Büppel, es ist halt USB-C.
Und die USB-C-Adapter, die ich habe, sind im Prinzip einfach nur ein sehr kurzes Kabel in Plastikform.
Ich hatte am Anfang ein bisschen Bedenken mit der Stabilität.
Tatsächlich, die haben hier so einen kleinen Knopf hinten und die gehen gar nicht so leicht raus.
Und wenn der Knopf nicht gedrückt ist, gehen sie halt auch gar nicht raus.
Und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, mein Thinkpad hat auch zwei USB-C-Anschlüsse.
Und ich vertraue den USB-C-Anschlüssen an diesem Laptop deutlich stärker als beim Thinkpad.
Echt, ja?
Bei dem Thinkpad habe ich immer Angst, dass es gleich abbricht, wenn ich das Kabel reinstecke.
Ich würde es nicht ausprobieren, so sehr vertraue ich ihm doch nicht.
Aber ich würde behaupten, man kann den Laptop easy am USB-C-Stecker aufhängen.
Wie ist denn das hier? Power-mäßig? Du lädst das auch über USB-C?
Ja, es lädt über USB-C.
An einen beliebigen Port?
An einen beliebigen Port, ja.
So schön.
Und er hat auch auf beiden Seiten zwischen den Ports eine Power-LED, also eine Lade-LED.
Was ist, wenn du alle diese vier Ports austauscht und keinen USB-C-Port?
Naja, dann kannst du halt nicht mehr laden. Das ist dann halt dein Problem.
Du kannst natürlich einen Port rausnehmen und das Kabel so innen reinstecken, aber das ist halt ein bisschen unbequem.
ich habe tatsächlich jetzt dreimal
USB-C, weil ich habe einen USB-C-Dunkel, an den
alles rangeht und ich möchte gerne links und rechts
laden können, weil ich finde, das ist ein geiles Feature
einfach mit die Seiten aus dem USB-C
und dann habe ich halt einmal USB-A, weil manchmal
braucht man das halt noch
das ist schön, dass die Möglichkeit besteht, weil ich brauche halt für USB-A einen Adapter
würde in diesen Port eine SD-Karte reinpassen?
es gibt glaube ich auch welche mit SD-Karten lese
es gibt auch 2TB
SSDs, die du da reinstecken kannst, die sind dann halt
zu, aber ich meine, ich kann schon
in eine 2TB in Form eSSD reinstecken
und dann will ich mir nicht noch ein Sport.
Aber ich habe jetzt dieses Teil in der Hand, da ist ein QR-Code
drauf und wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe,
wenn ich jetzt das Gehäuse hier aufschreiben würde,
hätte ich auch auf jeder Komponente innerhalb
des Gehäuses einen kleinen
QR-Code
mit einem Link zu einer Beschreibung,
wie ich es disassemble und wo ich Ersatzteile
dafür bestelle. Ich habe tatsächlich nicht so sehr
drauf geachtet. Also hier, da wo ich
das Ding rausgenommen habe, ein QR-Code im Gehäuse,
aber ich habe,
weil ich ein schlauer Mensch bin, habe ich
Fotos gemacht. Also ich habe mir
das Do-It-Yourself-Kit bestellt.
Das heißt, du hast den komplett selber zusammengebaut?
Nein. Also es gibt
quasi Fertiglaptops und die kommen halt aber alle
mit Windows und die sind dann quasi fertig zusammengestellt.
Ach, das DIY steht nur für Software, oder was?
Es ist halb-halb.
Also du bekommst, sind quasi
fertig zusammengebaut, aber da
du SSD und RAM
von Hand quasi beliebig bestellen
kannst, kannst du
bekommst du die, die bauen sie
halt nicht ein. Du musst den halt einmal aufmachen,
baust die SSD und den RAM ein,
was ja super easy ist. Und dann hast du natürlich kein Betriebssystem drauf.
Und dann hast du halt kein Betriebssystem drauf. Das Coole
daran ist, der Laptop
hat die, ich hab
ein Thinkpad noch
und das hat 32 GB RAM
und einen Ryzen 7 und das hat irgendwie
2200 Euro gekostet.
Und dieser Laptop hier hat einen i7
und der hat auch 32 GB RAM und der hat
auch eine 2 TB NVMe SSD und der hat
1600 Euro gekostet.
Einfach, weil du kannst SSD und
Arbeitsspeicher dort mitbestellen, aber
sie auch einfach bei CyberPod bestellen, wo sie die Hälfte
kosten.
Und da du sie sowieso einbauen musst,
hast du auch noch nicht mal extra Aufwand,
weil sie würden die dir ja eh nur lose mitschicken.
Und die freuen sich auch, wenn du die, also,
das heißt, die freuen sich, aber das Konzept dahinter ist halt
auch, wenn du das eh noch von einem anderen Laptop hast,
in Form E-SSD von einem
alten Laptop, den du nicht mehr benutzen musst, die gibt es
mittlerweile auch schon eine ganze Weile. Stimmt, das heißt, ich könnte so eine
Gehirntransplantation machen, wo ich einfach die
SSD von meinem alten Laptop da reinsetze
und dann läuft der
plötzlich in den neuen Körper weiter.
Ja, und wenn ich halt irgendwann mal ein neues Mainboard brauche, weil ich gerne mehr CPU-Leistung haben will, also ich kann hier 64 GB Arbeitsspeicher reinstecken, ich denke, das reicht noch ein bisschen, dann kann ich halt aber meine SSD auch einfach mitnehmen, das ist halt super praktisch.
Und ich kann mir halt auch aussuchen, man kann halt auch mit dem Preis entsprechend dann handeln und sagen, okay, ich brauche eh nicht so viel Speicherplatz, ich will einfach eine kleinere SSD haben. Und das ist mir auch bei dem ThinkPad aufgefallen, als ich das ThinkPad bestellt habe.
Du hast halt Ausbaustufen, die gibt es halt so und die sind dann halt so.
Und du kannst irgendwie den fettesten i7 mit 8 GB Arbeitsspeicher bestellen, aber der ist halt eh aufgelötet und du kannst nichts ändern.
Und ganz ehrlich, ich bin der Meinung, dass das einfach nur Elektroschrott, der fertig produziert wird.
Oder es ist halt Leute für dumm verkaufen, weil den dicksten i7 kannst du mit 8 GB Arbeitsspeicher sowieso nicht auslasten.
Und ich finde, es ist sowieso eine Frechheit, einen 2000 Euro Laptop 2022 mit 8 GB Arbeitsspeicher zu verkaufen.
Aber das ist halt
im Prinzip Elektroschrott, der vom Band fällt.
Ja, das ist echt so.
Du hast vorhin gesagt, dass du den an sich
eigentlich ganz cool fühlst und er ist wirklich ein schönes,
schmales und trotzdem
recht vorzugfestes Gerät.
Aber die Tastatur ist noch
ein bisschen schwammig. Kann man
sich eine andere Tastatur mit anderen
mechanischen Tastatur
einbauen?
Also, ich glaube, so
fancy sind die Optionen noch nicht.
Also grundsätzlich zur Verarbeitung, ich finde,
sehr hochwertig verarbeitet. Das war auch so,
wo ich mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher war.
Das ist immer noch keine Werbeveranstaltung.
Das möchte ich hier betonen.
Nein, ich kann dann auch gleich noch ein bisschen zu den negativen Seiten kommen.
Du kannst richtig mal, also wenn ihr euch die positiven Aspekte
über diese Framework-Computer,
es gibt einige, angucken wollt.
Ich empfehle dieses Linus Tech Tips Video.
Oder schaut euch auf die Webseite selber.
Und auf die Webseite, der Typ verdient ja Geld an der Firma.
Aber jetzt, Johannes, es ist dein Computer.
Erzähl uns doch mal bitte, was du alles scheiße an dem Gerät.
Also, ich hätte tatsächlich
lieber ein mattes Display gehabt.
Aber der drin besteht ja.
Ja, das Problem ist halt,
damals, als ich ihn bestellt habe, gab es das halt schlicht und einfach nicht.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt ein glänzendes Display.
Die Farben sind cool, aber es glänzt halt,
es nervt halt ein bisschen, wenn man schlechtes Licht hat.
Das Problem ist halt, wenn ich mir ein mattes Display bestelle,
habe ich halt immer noch ein glänzendes Display rumliegen
und das kostet halt auch wieder Geld
und ich kann jetzt nicht einfach sagen,
ich tausche for free das Display aus.
Weil ich habe dann halt...
Dann lasst du ein Display rumliegen.
Das ist der Punkt. Es gibt zwar Upgrade-Optionen,
aber ein Upgrade beinhaltet halt auch immer,
dass man dann was Altes rumliegen hat.
Es wäre cool, wenn die so einen Community-Marketplace mit anbieten.
Gibt es tatsächlich.
Also ich weiß nicht, es ist mindestens geplant.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der schon fertig ist,
ob es den schon gibt, aber auf jeden Fall ist das
stark.
Es ist mindestens, also die Idee ist doch
definitiv da.
Es gibt ja für diese Slots hier
gibt es schon 3D-Gedruckte.
Deswegen muss ich gerade an dich denken, Kieran.
Ich habe Johannes vielleicht schon da was gedruckt.
hat mir eine Schublade gedruckt,
falls ich mal doch keinen USB-C-Slot brauche,
sondern eine kleine Schublade an meinem Laptop-Molsch.
Oh. Da kannst du drei
M&Ms reinpacken. Das gab es
früher, als wir noch CDs hatten.
Kann ich eine 2-Euro-Münze oder eine halbe
SD-Karte reinstecken? Oder wie der Typ, der das
Ding gebastelt hat,
in Cut-Design hat, meinte auch
ein paar Tropfen Wasser. Kann man
manchmal gebrauchen. Ja, vor allem in der Schublade
in deinem Laptop-Molsch.
Ich hatte neulich das Problem, dass ich mit dem
Rennrad unterwegs war und kein Bargeld dabei hatte.
Manchmal sollte man an den Geräten,
die man mit sich herumträgt,
auch ein bisschen Geld deponieren.
Ein Kumpel von mir hat immer einen Zwanni
unterm Sattel.
Spannend. Aber gibt es da irgendwie so,
ich meine, von 3D gedruckten Komponenten,
die wahrscheinlich relativ simpel in der Funktionalität sind,
gibt es Ideen von Third-Party-Herstellern,
da irgendwie Custom-Hardware,
vielleicht so ein SIM-Card-Dings-Tray?
Ich habe die geilste Idee gerade.
Das sind ja links und rechts zwei Slots.
Beide belegen mit irgendwas?
Du kannst einfach, du machst aus dem Laptop
einen Quadcopter.
Das ist so stabil.
Der Akku reicht
wahrscheinlich eine Weile, dass das Ding schwebt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der vom Gewicht her, aber
das ist genau aus der anderen Richtung.
Ja, also
ich weiß tatsächlich nicht, ob es
Sachen von Third-Party-Herstellen gibt. Ich glaube,
die meisten Sachen sind halt Community oder
was Framework selbst anbietet.
Was ich halt schon gesehen habe, beispielsweise das Ethernet,
den Ethernet-Adapter, den du angesprochen hast,
Das ist so ein Ding, der ist aus der Community
gekommen und Framework hat halt gesagt,
okay, der ist so cool,
wir nehmen den in unser Sortiment auf.
Cool, okay.
Weil wir den sinnvoll finden und weil der halt auch
entsprechend gut designt war.
Aber ich sollte über die negativen Sachen reden.
Also ein, was ist mir aufgefallen,
aber ich glaube, das ist so ein Ding mit IPS-Displays.
Wenn ich den Bildschirm schwarz mache
und halt, also ein schwarzes Bild anzeige,
dann hat der unten so einen kleinen,
hellen Punkt.
Hab ich auch.
Ein Freund von mir hat das auf seinem Steam Deck, der hat versucht, das zurückzuschicken und die haben halt gesagt, das passiert halt, das ist ein IPS-Space, da kommt das halt hin und wieder vor und anscheinend habe ich jetzt Pech gehabt hier.
Mein Monitor zu Hause hat auch so ein paar Punkte, aber ganz ehrlich, selbst wenn man Filme schaut, selbst wenn da schwarze Balken unten sind, man merkt das eigentlich nicht.
Man sieht das wirklich nur, wenn der Laptop gerade angeht und halt den schwarzen Bildschirm zeigt beim Booten, dann sieht man es, aber sobald man irgendwas anderes hat, was nicht schwarz ist, dann fällt es eigentlich nicht mehr auf.
Aber es hat jetzt nichts mit dem Laptop an sich zu tun.
bei jedem anderen Laptop haben.
In meinem konkreten Fall
ist es halt so ein Detailperfekt
Sennonismus, wo ich halt denke,
es wäre cooler, wenn es einfach nicht da wäre.
Man hat viel Geld dafür ausgegeben, klar.
Das ist der Punkt. Und ja, die Tastatur, ich meine,
ich komme von einem ThinkPad. ThinkPad-Tastaturen
sind halt einfach schon sehr, sehr gut,
was Laptop-Tastaturen betrifft.
Die Tasten, ich finde,
sie sind okay. Also wenn du hier die Tastatur
austauschen würdest, müsstest du die gesamte
Oberfläche von dem
Chassis austauschen? Also das nicht.
Also es gibt quasi einzelne Tastaturen.
Wenn du ein Layout haben willst, was quasi nicht in dieses Chassis reinpasst, dann wahrscheinlich schon.
Aber man sieht, das Chassis ist schon entsprechend gebaut.
Also es gibt beispielsweise keinen Trenner zwischen der linken Shift-Taste und den spitzen Klammern.
Ah ja, wenn du auch eine breite Taste haben könntest.
Und auch die Enter-Taste und die Raute-Taste sind so geformt,
dass man quasi sowohl ein Ansie- als auch ein ISO-Layout in das gleiche Chassis einbauen könnte.
Ach so heißen die, okay.
Das heißt, das mit der hohen Enter-Taste ist ein ISO-Layout.
Das ist ein falsches Layout.
In der breiten Enter-Taste nutzen das richtige Layout.
Genau.
Kieran und ich haben beide einen
Ansi-Layout, sehe ich gerade.
Und das Coole ist tatsächlich, sie haben auch die Enter-Taste
so geformt und auch die Shift-Taste, dass quasi
zwischen den Tasten dann auch trotzdem noch diese
haptische Lücke ist, sodass man sie halt trotzdem noch
fühlt. Was für mich sehr wichtig ist,
weil ich mag das überhaupt nicht, wenn ich die Tasten
einzeln nicht fühlen kann. Weißt du, was bei dieser
Tastatur komplett richtig ist? Das ist, dass die
Fn-Taste nicht die ganz linksaußen
ist, sondern das ganz linksaußen die
Steuerung-Taste ist. Ja.
Das ist, ich weiß nicht was, also das ist das eigentlich, ich meine, okay, ich merke es bei meinem ThinkPad nicht, weil ich gehe immer ins BIOS und stelle es einfach immer um.
Ich hatte, bei meinem ersten MacBook habe ich dann die Tasten ausgetauscht, aber, oder bei irgendeinem Computer wurde es, nee, es kann auch ein ThinkPad gewesen sein, bei irgendeinem Computer hatte ich diese Tasten ausgetauscht, aber beim nächsten Computer waren dann die Fn-Taste und die Control-Taste nicht gleich breit.
Und das heißt, ich konnte den Key nicht einfach hart ausreißen und umtauschen.
Bei Thinkpads ist es leider so, dass sind die halt vertauscht. Ich weiß nicht, was sich Lenovo dabei gedacht hat. Man kann es Gott sei Dank in Bios umstellen, weil dann doch irgendwer bei Lenovo weiß, wie richtige Menschen das benutzen wollen.
Oder man gewöhnt sich einfach dran.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein kulturelles Ding.
Es ist ein Gaming-Ding, dass du einfach mit dem linken kleinen Finger immer crouchen willst in der Ecke und da kann einfach nicht die Äpfel-Tasse sein.
Es gibt glaube ich die Fraktion Menschen, die
Steuerung Shift
mit Kleinfinger, Ringfinger
drücken.
Und das geht zum Beispiel auf dem Mac,
wo der Fn auch ganz links ist,
geht das halt schlecht, da drückst du
Shift Fn.
Und es gibt halt, auf dem Mac
ist es so, dass du diese ganzen Control-Option-
Command-Keys alle mit dem Daumen drückst.
Und da ist es dann irgendwie sinnvoll,
dass die es, aber es ist
irgendwie weird.
würde ich behaupten, dass das auch nicht
so generalisierbar ist, aber
naja, klar. Layouts sind anders.
Das ist richtig. Ich habe tatsächlich mit
dem Layout von dem
Framework-Laptop so ein paar kleine
Sachen, die mich daran stören.
Das eine sind die F-Tasten.
Die sind halt
gleichmäßig
gespaced, das heißt,
ich mag das lieber in Vierergruppen,
das ist halt wahrscheinlich einfach eine Gewöhnheitssache.
Die F12-Taste ist für
meinen Empfinden sehr weit rechts. Ich drücke dann
auf 11, wenn ich auf 12 drücke, das ist ein bisschen nervig.
Und auch
entfernen ist halt dann irgendwie rechts neben
12 und einfügen ist halt
Fn entfernen, was ich auch ein bisschen...
Der Power-Button ist nicht auf der Tastatur, sondern auch
das ist ein Feature. Der Power-Button ist nicht
auf der Tastatur.
Was ich auch irgendwie ein bisschen dumm finde,
aber es ist mir auch bei anderen Marken aufgefallen,
es gibt diese
geteilte Pfeil-Hoch-Pfeil-Runter-Taste
und die Pfeile nach links und rechts
haben dann die volle Größe.
und Bild auf und Bild ab sind irgendwie FN,
diese Tasten, während Lenovo einfach
die Links- und Rechtspfeile auch geteilt hat
in der Horizontalen
und halt einfach Bild hoch, Bild runter
als separate Tasten gemacht. Aber ich bin da vielleicht
auch speziell, wie ich meine Tastatur haben möchte.
Tastatur-Layouts, all Layouts,
auch beautiful.
Aber ansonsten ja,
der
Einschaltknopf ist nicht auf der Tastatur,
das finde ich sehr gut. Tatsächlich ist er auch ein
Fingerabdruckleser. Schön. Ich glaube,
Fingerabdruckleser sind einfach mit laufende
Ich benutze ihn nicht, weil ich meine, dass
Biometrie kein Authentifizierungsverfahren
ist, weil wer ändert schon mal seinen Fingerabdruck?
Ich rotiere meine Finger regelmäßig durch.
Ich hatte letztens
Es ist ein
Authentifizierungsmechanismus
aber kein valider
Identifizierungsmechanismus.
Ja, und es ist halt
Authentifizierung
ist okay, aber du möchtest
dich darüber nicht identifizieren lassen, weil du kannst
nicht, das ist nochmal,
aber das ist ein ganz anderes. Ja, also
irgendwo hatte ich auch mal gelesen, dass eine Bank sich dachte, hey, wir
können doch bestimmt Kreditkarten super safe machen,
indem wir halt einfach so einen Fingerabdruckleser einbauen
und der Punkt ist halt,
ich meine, mittlerweile wissen die meisten Leute
oder mittlerweile ist das Wissen, wie
man so einen Fingerabdruck mit so ein bisschen Silikon
nachbaut, jetzt nicht so krass. Ja, das ist nur ein Stück
Tesa. Es gibt irgendwo,
dass man mittlerweile nur noch mit dem Handabdruck
oder mit dem Fingerabdruck bezahlt. Und ich meine, gerade
also gerade auf Kreditkarten ist es ja mega dumm,
weil die sind ja so glattes Plastik, das heißt, dahinter lässt man
die ganze Zeit schon Fingerabdrücke drauf.
Stimmt, der ist eigentlich da die ganze Zeit drauf.
Und da einen Fingerabdruckleser drauf zu machen, ist irgendwie mega dumm.
Was mich tatsächlich
ein bisschen stört, es gibt keine
LED außen, wenn man ihn
zuklappt. Du Thinkpad-Nutzer, du.
Naja, ich hab da nie
drüber nachgedacht beim Thinkpad, weil beim Thinkpad,
wenn es im Standby ist, dann blinkt die LED halt außen.
Und die LED hier,
die ist halt dann verdeckt vom Display,
die am Einschaltknopf ist.
Und du siehst den Laptop von außen.
Aber fährst du ihn wirklich runter?
Hin und wieder schon.
Wie lange hält der?
Ich meine, es ist ein Intel-Chip drin.
Ich habe den jetzt die ganze...
Eben.
Ich habe eine Abteilung von 40 Tagen.
Ja, 41 Tage.
Also ich habe den jetzt die ganze Zeit, die wir da sind, hier laufen auf irgendwie...
Naja, nicht Superhelm-Display, aber der ist schon die ganze Zeit an.
Der ist jetzt bei 62 Prozent und hat noch vier Stunden Zeit.
Das klingt doch...
Und ich finde, das ist ganz solide dafür, dass ich die ganze Zeit zumindest mindestens mal den Browser offen habe
und links öffne und was mache und das WLAN läuft.
und das Display vor allem läuft.
Ich finde, also
ich bin, ich weiß nicht, ich bin
sowieso mit, also
ich brauche selten richtig krass viel
Akkulaufzeit. Meistens bin ich eh,
also wenn ich unterwegs bin, bin ich meistens
mit dem Zug unterwegs und selbst da hat man mittlerweile
überall Steckdosen. Zumindest da, wo man
sinnvollen Laptop verwenden kann, hat man meistens überall
Steckdosen und damit ist es
halt kein so krasses Problem mehr.
Ja, aber wie gesagt,
es gibt keine LED außen, die blinken,
wenn er im Standby ist. Das ist
ein bisschen stört, aber das Feature
Max hatten das früher ja auch, die hatten vorne dran
diese kleine sleeping
weiße LED, die du nicht gesehen hast, weil die unter dem
Plastik, unter dem Schutz war
und da habe ich ein kleines Plastik drüber
und die hat auch so schön poesiert wie so ein Atmen
Ja, also der Punkt ist
der Punkt ist halt leider auch
es sind ja sogar zwei LEDs, die von außen
sichtbar sind
Das wäre jetzt ein Custom
Stecker, den du da ranmachen könntest
Der hat ja sogar außen LEDs drin
Das heißt, wenn du den lädst, dann ist das die Lade-LED und die ist auch rot oder weiß, je nachdem, ob er halt lädt oder voll ist.
Aber die könnte auch blinken, wenn er im Standby ist und man ihm zuklappt.
Aber gerade du bist auch wahrscheinlich dazu am besten equipped, die Firma von dem Ding ein bisschen zu optimieren.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich auch, was auch immer für ein Chips, das da ist, würde ich A, darauf portieren und dann hätte ich keine Lust mehr.
Der andere Punkt ist tatsächlich, es klingt nach einem interessanten Projekt,
Aber auf einem Gerät, was ich tatsächlich benutzen will, will ich ungern mit der Firmware rumdebuggen.
Also brauchst du noch einen zweiten.
Ja, ich brauche einen Development Kit für die Firmware.
Das ist eine Kundequenz.
Was es jetzt zum Beispiel passieren könnte, was es ja von denen auch gibt, ist, wenn du jetzt deine CPU upgradest, dann hast du also hinterher aus dem Gerät quasi nur das Mainboard ausgebaut.
der Rest vom Computer ist noch da.
Das heißt, wenn es nicht kaputt war,
ein vollständig funktionsfähiges, aber ohne
Peripherie bestehendes
Mainboard. Und dafür haben wir, glaube ich, extra noch
Gehäuse, dass du das Mainboard in eine
Kiste einbauen kannst, um einen
separaten Rechner daraus zu machen.
Genau, ich glaube, von Cooler Master gibt es so ein 3D-druckbares
Gehäuse.
Und das ist im Prinzip
einfach nur ein Housing ums Mainboard. Da ist jetzt nichts
fancy dran. Das ist dann das Second Life für das
ausgemusterte Mainboard.
Und wenn man dann halt das Ding irgendwann
verwenden möchte. Ich überlege auch, ob ich meinen alten Laptop als Homeserver verwende,
wenn meine Homeserver, der mittlerweile auch schon mal zehn Jahre alt ist, irgendwann mal kaputt geht.
Und das ist halt cool, weil dann muss man halt nicht den ganzen Rest vom Laptop mit weiterverwenden,
den man ja dann sowieso nicht mehr braucht.
Ich habe tatsächlich mal früher, hat mir jemand einen Laptop gebracht, bei dem war das Display kaputt.
Und er hat ihn aber halt noch an einem Bildschirm verwendet.
Und das war aber so umständlich mit dem Aufklappen und Zuklappen.
Und ich habe dann den Laptop auseinandergebaut.
Ich habe das Display ausgebaut und habe ihn dann wieder zusammengebaut.
Und es ist halt quasi so ein Tastaturcomputer,
wie man ihn halt aus den 80ern kennt geworden.
Geil.
Wie ist der Pi, der in der Tastatur mit Embedded war?
Der 400.
400 war das, ja.
Ja, also das habe ich noch.
Ich habe die Leute am Max, das war irgendwie so ein Twitter-Ding,
das mal irgendwie kurzzeitig so viral
ging, dass super viele Leute ihren Mac
die Displays rausnehmen
und das MacBook als
Tastaturcomputer nutzen.
Okay, klar.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr warum.
Ich habe das damals mit einem Acer-Laptop gemacht,
das hat auch funktioniert.
Das ist nicht so premium wie ein Mac, aber...
Aber sag mal, die haben doch auf der Webseite,
zeigen sie auch, dass du
Sachen wie das Tastaturpanel zur Seite rutschen
kann, um noch ein NumPad-Modul daneben zu setzen.
Ist das eine andere Form des Firmware-Laptops?
Das sind diese 16-Zoll-Geräte?
Genau, also sie haben jetzt neu rausgebracht, also das, was ich habe, ist der 13 Zoll Laptop, das ist 13,5 Zoll.
Für die Leute, die ein Thinkpad, ein T14, 14 Zoll Thinkpad zu Hause haben, der ist genauso tief und dick wie das Thinkpad, nur ein kleines bisschen schmaler.
Hendrik vermisst gerade am MacBook Air Displaymaße.
Hat übrigens ein 3 zu 2 Display, was ich auch sehr cool finde.
Das ist eigentlich nice, ja.
Und es gibt mittlerweile auch ein 16-Sort-Laptop für Leute, die lieber einen größeren Laptop haben.
Und da sind natürlich viel, viel mehr Möglichkeiten verfügbar.
Und da kannst du dann entweder links und rechts gute Lautsprecher haben, wie ein normaler Mensch.
Oder du machst dir so ein Thriller-Setup.
Du kannst theoretisch sogar drei NumPads nebeneinander machen.
Aber das Spannende ist ja, dass die Konnektivität da irgendwie geregelt ist.
Dass du verschiedene Pads hast, wo du dann Hardware drauf mounten kannst.
Also sind das irgendwelche Pogo-Pins?
Das werden ja schon keine hochkantigen USB-C-Ports darunter sein.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen so.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe meinen Fairphone noch nie auseinandergebracht tatsächlich.
Aber ich glaube, die verwenden auch solche flachen Konnektoren,
wo du halt viele Pins nebeneinander hast,
die du dann halt im Prinzip nur ganz flach aufsteckst.
Ich glaube, sowas ist eine Art.
Du hast dann verschiedene Punkte, wo du bestimmte Module drauflegen kannst.
Du kannst die Tastatur in die Mitte legen, aber auch nach links oder nach rechts.
Und daneben hast du dann Platz für zum Beispiel Numpad oder Lautsprecher links und rechts.
Und in dem Beispielvideo auf der Webseite ziehen sie die Lautsprecher nach unten rechts, damit Platz ist für Tastatur und Numpad nebeneinander.
Und das Trackpad schieben sie dann auch nach links.
Das ist schon ganz cool, weil das für eine Möglichkeit du da hast.
Ja, die haben auch noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Die haben auch noch einen Slot hinten drin, wo du entweder eine GPU einbauen kannst oder ich glaube irgendwie noch einen größeren Akku.
Was halt ziemlich cool ist, weil ich meine, bei so einem größeren Gerät will man vielleicht eine GPU haben.
Das war witzig, weil wenn du den Akku rausnimmst
und eine GPU reinsteckst, verbrennst du so oder so viel mehr Strom.
Und wenn du die GPU
drin hast, dann bringt dir auch der Akku nichts mehr.
Ja, ich meine, das ist
ganz ehrlich, ich hatte
ich habe bei allen meinen Laptops drauf geachtet,
dass ich einfach keine GPU habe, sondern nur
den Onboard-Grafik-Chip
SZ2. Nichts, was ich auf einem Laptop mache,
bräuchte eine GPU
und ich möchte auf dem Laptop auch gar nichts machen,
eine GPU oder eine leistungsfähige
GPU braucht, weil
der Laptop
halt auch einfach thermisch
nicht die Fähigkeiten hat, die ganze
Wärme abzuführen. Mobile
GPUs sind schon herrlich underpowered und
bekloppt. Also nicht bekloppt, also ich habe eine
Daseinsberechtigung, aber typischerweise, also
gerade bei dir weiß ich auch, dass du andere Hardware nutzt für das,
was eine GPU benötigt. Dafür gibt es
halt dann den Desktop-PC
oder das Steam Deck.
Ja, der Punkt ist halt,
der Desktop-PC hat halt
Ich meine, für viele Leute ist ja, da ist halt irgendwie die andere Hardware drin, aber allein die Tatsache, dass halt ein großes Gehäuse mit viel Luftvolumen hat, gibt einfach so viel mehr Möglichkeiten, das sinnvoll zu kühlen.
Ich meine, das Luftvolumen, was ich brauche, um eine bestimmte Temperatur abzusenken, das bleibt ja quasi das Gleiche.
Ich kann ja nur x Liter Luft um x Grad aufwärmen, wenn ich x Grad Temperatur abführen will.
Und bei einem großen Gehäuse habe ich einfach viel Volumen, das durchschieben kann.
Und bei einem kleinen Gehäuse muss ich das halt nur über die Geschwindigkeit der Luft, die durch das Gehäuse fliegt, machen.
Und wir alle wissen, dass kleine Lüfter mit hohen Drehzahlen keine schöne Sache sind.
Das ist halt not even close, was da der Unterschied ist.
Und tatsächlich, wenn der hier auf Volllast läuft, dann wird er verhält.
Ich finde das schon tatsächlich ziemlich laut, aber er dreht dann auch relativ zeitnah wieder runter.
Ich habe irgendwo mal nachgelesen, vielleicht mache ich das irgendwann mal, dass man den quasi eher, also der lüftet erst ziemlich spät und man kann dann quasi einstellen, dass er eher anfängt zu lüften.
Damit wird halt die Gesamttemperatur nicht so hoch. Das heißt, er lüftet zwar früher, aber leiser.
Aber bei kleineren Drehteil, ja.
Und jetzt lüftet er halt später, was halt cool ist, wenn du nicht bis an den Punkt kommst, weil dann lüftet er halt seltener.
Aber wenn er halt lüftet, dann lüftet er. Das ist auch so ein Manko. Das mag ich nicht ganz so sehr. Die Thinkpads sind da tatsächlich leiser.
Ich hatte zwischendurch auch mal ein Thinkpad, das war verhältnismäßig laut.
Mein altes L440 ist sehr, sehr leise, aber das ist auch dreimal so dick.
Da ist einfach mehr Luftvolumen drin.
Meinst du, dass da wirklich Luft drin ist?
Nein, da ist nicht so viel Luft drin, aber ich glaube, die Lüfter sind insgesamt schon größer als das, was bei den modernen Thinkpads der Fall ist.
Weil das Mainboard ist nicht dicker.
Was dick ist, ist vor allem das DVD-Laufwerk und halt der Akku.
Und dann hat man noch irgendwo ein bisschen mehr Luft übrig gehabt.
Und da wurde dann halt im Prinzip mehr Lüfter eingebaut, um mehr Luftvolumen einfach durchzubekommen.
Heutzutage hat kein Laptop mehr ein CD-Laufwerk.
Wenn du darüber nachdenkst, dass ein Laptop überhaupt mal ein CD-Laufwerk hatte.
Ich finde das tatsächlich interessant.
Das letzte Mal eine DVD...
Ich erinnere mich noch früher, wie ich mal DVD-Rohlinge gekauft habe.
Und man hat immer neue gebraucht und die waren irgendwie immer leer.
Und irgendwann war das schlagartig vorbei und man hat so eine 50er Spindel,
die einfach nie wieder leer geworden ist.
Das war wirklich so ein Zack.
Und ich finde das auch krass, wie schlagartig das passiert ist.
Und das andere ist tatsächlich, ich habe dann auch sehr lange gar keine DVD mehr gebrannt.
Und dann kann man eine Diplomarbeit und da musste ich zur Abgabe drei DVDs brennen.
Und ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass jemals ein Brennvorgang fehlgeschlagen ist,
wenn man einfach nur, keine Ahnung, x Dateien auf eine DVD brennt.
Und ich glaube, das ist das, wo das BitRot einsetzt.
Es ist einfach über Jahre,
hat wahrscheinlich niemand diese Software ernsthaft benutzt.
Und ich habe für meine zwei DVDs,
die ich für meine Typenarbeit abgeben musste,
drei Rohlinge gebraucht,
weil der erste Brennvorgang fehlgeschlagen ist.
Und das ist mir noch nie passiert.
Weil die Rohlinge so alt waren?
Nein, die waren gar nicht.
Ich musste neu kaufen,
weil ich habe die 50er Spindel nicht mehr gefunden.
Ja, aber du hast die neu gekauft.
Wir standen vorher 20 Jahre beim Media Markt.
Entweder das oder einfach die Software, keine Ahnung,
oder das DVD-Laufwerk war zu lange.
Aber ich finde das interessant.
Ich finde das interessant, dass es halt einfach so lange so zuverlässig funktioniert hat
und mit der gleichen Hardware fünf Jahre später auf einmal geht das nicht mehr.
Doch, ich hatte früher auch schon Brenn-Failures.
Das ist schon ein Ding gewesen.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern.
Ich erinnere mich noch an meinem ersten PC, da hatte ich zwei DVD-Lofwerke,
damit ich Spiele schneller installieren konnte
und damit man gleichzeitig, damit man direkt 1-2-1-Kopien machen konnte,
ohne dass man sie zwischendurch auf die Uhr langsame Festplatte schreiben musste.
Ich hatte einmal den Fall, da habe ich ein Spiel von einem Freund ausgeliehen.
Das war das Sims 1
Magic Add-on
Expansion Pack, wie auch immer das hieß.
Total toll.
Und ich habe das über Nacht in meinem PC gelassen,
habe den PC gebootet.
Beim Bootvorgang drehten die Laufwerke natürlich immer kurz hoch,
um zu schauen, ob da was Bootbares drin liegt.
Und plötzlich, also das Laufwerk
fährt hoch, plötzlich tut es einen mega lauten Schlag
und dann mache ich das Laufwerk auf.
Das Laufwerk fährt nur irgendwie so drei Zentimeter raus und ich sehe
Splitter von der CD drin liegen.
Und die hat irgendwie zerfetzt in dem Laufwerk.
Aber ich hatte dann, ich weiß nicht,
wer der Hersteller von dem Laufwerk war, die habe ich angeschrieben
und ich habe, glaube ich, EA angeschrieben.
Und wir beiden hat gesagt, ja,
ich bin 14,
ich habe mir dieses Spiel von einem Freund ausgeliehen,
wie kann denn sowas sein? Ich weiß gar nicht, warum
sie EA geschrieben haben, aber die haben ja eigentlich das Spiel gebraucht.
Aber der Laufwerkhersteller
hat mir das Spiel ersetzt
und ein neues Laufwerk geschickt und
EA hat mir auch irgendwas geschickt gehabt,
so ein Mitleidspaket. Und das fand ich irgendwie
nett.
Ich dachte, solche Geschichten gab es bloß in den 80ern.
So einfach eigentlich.
Mein, also es gab so in einer Sitcom aus den 80ern den Streit, der, wie hieß denn dieses Soundblaster, was du auf der Schulter getragen hast?
Ein Ghettoblaster.
Dein Ghettoblaster hat meine MC-Kassette gefressen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, den weirdesten Hardwarefehler, den ich hatte, den hatte ich damals mit meinem Athlon 64 X2.
der Rechner lief einfach alles ganz normal.
Irgendwo machte es so Klonk und ich habe
das aber nicht so wirklich für voll genommen.
Drei Sekunden später ging der Rechner aus.
Ich so, okay.
Ich glaube, so etwas hatte ich auch schon mal.
Dann habe ich ihn angemacht und dann
ist er wieder nochmal hochgefahren.
Zehn Sekunden später ging er wieder aus.
Ich glaube, das ist genau das gleiche Problem.
Dann habe ich ihn nochmal hochgefahren, da bin ich
ins Bios gegangen.
Da war er schon bei 105 Grad.
Okay, jetzt weiß ich, warum er ausging.
Ist der Kühlkörper abgefallen?
Genau.
Ich hab Starcraft gespielt in dem Moment.
Und ich hab dann das Gehäuse aufgemacht und dachte mir so, der Kühlkörper ist locker.
Und da ist halt die Adlon-Dinger, die hatten halt so einen Plastikring
und da waren halt so zwei Nasen und die eine Nase ist halt abgebrochen.
Und ich hab eigentlich Schwein gehabt, dass es die untere Nase war.
Wäre es die obere gewesen, wäre der Kühlkörper voll auf die Grafikkarte gefallen.
Ich nicht.
Bei mir ist das Ding runtergeklappt.
Du hast halt damals bei den CPUs, da hast du ja richtig Geld ausgegeben,
so einen richtig möglichst massiven, großen, schweren
Kühlkörper.
Kupferkühlkörper. Genau, irgendein
krasses Ding. Und bei mir ist es
nicht ganz runtergeklappt, weil es
so nah an der Außenwand
von dem Gehäuse, dass es einfach
gegen das Gehäuse geknallt ist und dann
nicht weiter umgekippt ist. Aber
auch diese Plastennasen waren kaputt
und dafür gibt es keine Ersatzteile. Also
hättest du entweder ein neues Mainboard kaufen
können oder es
gibt Kühlkörper,
die Mainboard unabhängig
sind oder generisch sind
und die bringen dann ihre eigene Halterung mit,
die man dann auf das Mainboard schraubt.
Tatsächlich
hatte ich noch ein Mainboard
zu Hause rumliegen, das war defekt
und es hatte aber die gleichen Sockel und alles
und ich habe dann von dem defekten Mainboard
diesen AMD-Kühlkörperhalter
abgebaut
und ihn an mein funktionierendes
Mainboard herangebaut. Also ich weiß nicht mehr, aus welchem
Grund ich das alte nicht weggeschmissen habe, aber es war
ein sehr glücklicher Zufall. Und damit ging
der Rechner dann noch ein paar Jahre.
Aber das Bittere war echt, ich dachte
so, naja, wie schwer kann das sein? Machst du vorne
vier Schrauben locker und dann
ziehst du es ab und dann machst du den
anderen vier Schrauben locker und dann ziehst du es dran, bis ich
gelernt habe, dass die Kühlkörperhalter so
festgemacht wurden,
dass du sie von hinten vom
Mainboard lösen musstest. Das heißt, du musstest
das Mainboard aus dem Gehäuse ausbauen,
um dieses Scheißding
zu wechseln. Ich hatte bei meinem ersten
selbstgebauten PC, hatte ich echt
und hatte irgendwie Hilfe von einem Kumpel, den zusammenzubauen.
Und nach ein paar Monaten geht das Mainboard kaputt.
Und dann, wenn das Mainboard kaputt ist,
muss er alles auseinanderbauen.
Dann habe ich das Mainboard eingeschickt
und ein Ersatzgerät gekriegt vom Support.
Und das hatte nach ein paar Wochen denselben Defekt.
Und ich habe an diesem PC insgesamt drei oder vier Mal
das Mainboard ausgetauscht.
Und zum Schluss war ich eigentlich ziemlich gut darin.
Das war wie so ein Boxenstopp.
Du machst die Seite auf und machst das gesamte Ding auseinander.
Ich habe gar keinen Bock auf so hart.
Was ich ja immer noch faszinierend finde, ist, dass sie die haben.
Deswegen hast du ja auch einen MacBook und kein Framework.
Ich habe zu Hause ja auch so einen Desktop-PC rumstehen.
Und da habe ich letztens das Problem gehabt.
Ich habe letztens, das ist jetzt auch zwei Jahre her,
vielleicht sogar länger, online einen Artikel gelesen.
Es gibt so Netzteile.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, welche Firma das war.
Die haben irgendwie so ein lustiges Problem.
Die fangen halt irgendwann Brandomes Feuer.
What the fuck?
Das ist ja blöd für die Leute, die das haben.
Schau so in mein Pächer.
Fuck, ich habe exakt dieses Modell.
Dann kann ich damit ja nicht mehr ruhig schlafen.
Dann habe ich extra so eine smarte Steckdose gekauft.
Das Ding daran geschlossen, dass ich den immer komplett
vom Strom nehmen kann, wenn ich ihn nicht benutze.
Aber auf Dauer konnte ich trotzdem nicht leben.
Habe so ein neues 850-Vat-Netzteil gekauft
und irgendwann das Ding getauscht.
Ich hatte halt gar keinen Bock, weil die Kabel sind ja auch
nicht komplett standardisiert.
Das ist das, weshalb du dir den zusammengebauten Rechner
kaufst, damit du nicht diesen Kabelsalat da drin hast.
Ich empfehle euch,
kauft euch ein modulares Netzteil.
Das ist dann ein modulares Netzteil gewesen.
Aber trotzdem, diese ganzen Kabel zu tauschen und zu wissen,
und du musst ja ein bisschen Management betreiben von wegen,
ja, ich habe noch diesen Dreierstecker und der muss ja
dahin und dieser Zweierstecker, der muss da runter,
aber das Kabel ist länger als das andere.
Das ist die Kunst und deswegen machst du dann
irgendwann, deswegen gibt es
Fotos von solchen Sachen gut gemacht
auf Oddly Satisfying.
Am schlimmsten finde ich dann immer, wenn man
diesen 24-Pin
Mainboard-Stecker an diesem
ultra fetten Kabel, weil irgendwo müssen die 24-Leitungen
herkommen,
hat und dann hat man ihn ganz schön
durchgeführt und dann ist er falsch rum und mausten
das ultra fette, super steife Kabel
um 180 Grad
aber
das Lustige ist immer, wenn ich an meinem Rechner rumgebaut
habe, ich vergesse konsequent
immer irgendwas wieder reinzustecken
oder anzuschalten und dann drücke ich auf
den Einschaltknopf und er geht einfach nicht hin.
Und das Adrenalinlevel, das dann spontan ansteigt.
Und ich habe
letztes Mal, das habe ich extra A
ich vergesse diesmal nicht, das Netzteil
wieder anzuschalten, ich mache mal das Netzteil aus, weil du willst
ja nicht irgendwas unter Strom rausziehen, weil
meistens wirklich kaputt.
Und dann hatte ich
das Netz zahen gemacht
und dann habe ich auch einen Knopf gerückt und es ging nicht
so scheiße.
Wenn ich dann mal geschnallt habe, dass du das Netz zahengeschaltet
aber den Stecker nicht reingesteckt hast.
Manchmal, wenn du es zum dritten Mal auseinanderbaust
und wieder zusammensteckst, vergisst du
den Kippschalter hinten.
Ich erinnere mich noch, als ich
2021 eine neue Grafikkarte
brauchte, weil ich gemerkt habe, dass meine alte den
neuen Bildschirm nicht mehr richtig
ansteuern konnte.
Was ja gerade zu dem Zeitpunkt war, als es keine Grafikkarten gab.
Scheiße.
Ich hatte auch nie wieder Grafikkarten. Warum?
Ich hatte eine verhältnismäßig günstige AMD-Grafikkart,
die sogar leistungsfähig war, die es sogar gab.
Und da gab es irgendwie noch fünf Modelle, fünf Stück von.
Und ich wusste halt aber nicht mehr,
ob ich zwei 8-Pin-Stecker an meinem Netzteil habe.
Und habe die Rechner runtergefahren, aufgeschraubt,
schnell nachgeguckt, zugeschraubt, hochgefahren und die waren weg.
Fuck.
Ach, die Grafikkarte
Die Grafikkarte
Blöd
Dann ist halt wieder eine Nvidia Grafikkarte geworden
Oh man
Wollen wir mal zu den Pix-Code
Das ist schon eine erstaunlich lange Folge
dieses Mal
Ich würde sagen, wir haben zwar noch
ein, zwei coole Themen, aber
ganz ehrlich, wir können auch eine Folge machen
Ja
Ich finde, das können wir wiederholen
Wir müssen nicht 25 Folgen warten, bis wir Johannes wieder einladen, finde ich.
Fünf Jahre. Exakt fünf Jahre.
Sind es dann 2028?
Genau, September, August.
Bitte, der Gast fängt an. Johannes.
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich da nur zwei Sachen verlinkt. Ich habe über beide schon geredet.
Das eine ist die Flipper Zero Wi-Fi Map, die ich irgendwann mal ausprobieren werde, wenn ich Zeit habe mit meinen ganzen anderen Projekten.
Und wenn die ADA Foundation für den ESP
drauf läuft.
Und das andere ist das
ADA Core, das ist das Record Flux
Paper über SPDM,
über das ich vorhin geredet habe.
Da kann man das alles nochmal im Detail
nachlesen. Bitte schaut euch jetzt den
Chapter Mark, ADA Core
etc.
Wäre witzig, wenn Chapter Mark irgendwie so eine
prozentuale Angabe hätten,
wie viel der Folge sie einnehmen.
Bei meinem Player ist es sogar
innerhalb der Chapters irgendwie ein Progress Bar.
Stimmt. Ja, okay, sowas.
Willst du weitermachen?
Ich möchte mal
fragen, ihr habt beide so einen Flipper.
Was macht man damit?
In der Grundausstattung ohne dieses
Wi-Fi-Dings. In der Grundausstattung hast du halt
Möglichkeiten, über Infrarot Spaß
zu haben, über Software-Defined-Radio Spaß
zu haben, also über Frequenzen
Dinge zu empfangen, zu schicken. Du kannst
diese iButton-Sensorik auf der
Rückseite nutzen, wofür ich noch keinen einzigen Use Case in meinem
Leben gefunden habe. Ich dachte, ja und die Kaffeemaschine
Maske lässt sich darüber administrieren, aber nein,
das ist kein iPad. Ich jedes Mal, wenn ich das Ding
sehe, frage ich mich, ob man dann mit die Kassen
im EDK...
Ich glaube, das könnten welche sein
und ich weiß, manche Firmen... Aber ich will es nicht ausprobieren.
Okay, ich glaube, da müssen wir mal eine
Sonderfolge drüber machen, weil das ist eine
ganze Menge Kontext drin.
Für NFC nutze ich es tatsächlich sehr häufig. Das ist das eine,
was ich bisher sehr viel mit...
Weil du da mit NFC-Karten klonst oder...
Da kannst du auch Spaß haben, aber
Ich sage meistens auch, wenn das dumm ist.
Ich habe fast alle Nintendo für der Switch diese Mies, diese Sammelfiguren, die an einem NFC-Chip einfach drauf haben.
Die Code hat auf dem Flipper drauf.
Die kann ich emulieren, weil meine Switch dran ist.
Ich habe tatsächlich eine Idee für ein Projekt, das werde ich vielleicht nie umsetzen.
Ich habe mir letztens eine Klimaanlage gekauft.
Ich habe vorher gegoogelt, ob man denn Klimaanlagen mit Home Assistant steuern kann.
So mobile Klimaanlagen.
Anscheinend gibt es keine, bei der das sinnvoll geht.
Aber die hat eine Fernbedienung.
Und was man halt mit dem Flipper Zero auch machen kann.
Dann können wir in der nächsten Folge über Home Assistant.
Man kann halt so von Fernbedienungen Codes aufnehmen.
Und ich habe das mal im Fernseher probiert.
Das funktioniert erstaunlich zuverlässig.
Also ich kann den auch relativ zuverlässig außen einschalten mit dem, was ich von der Fernbedienung aufgenommen habe.
Und naja, theoretisch könnte man sich ja dann so ein kleines Board mit einer Infrarot-LED löten.
Und dann kann man mit dem Flipper die ganzen Fernbedienungscodes von der Klimaanlagenfernbedienung analysieren.
Und dann halt das nachbauen.
Ich glaube, dadurch, dass du es jetzt schon innerhalb von wenigen Sätzen beschreiben konntest, gibt es das schon online, oder?
Ich habe noch nicht danach gesucht.
Ich habe noch nicht geguckt.
Ich habe in meinem Schlafzimmer einen Ventilator, der ich über eine Zigbee-Steckdose an- und ausmachen kann.
am liebsten hätte ich einen Ventilator, wo ich über Home Assistant
auch die
Intensität, wo ich sie wirklich
komplex steuern könnte.
Drehst du dich? Wie stark bist du?
Und so weiter und so fort. Und das gibt es irgendwie offenbar nur für
Deckenventilatoren. Die Frage ist,
wie macht man den Backchannel von der
Klimaanlage? Ich meine, die hat so ein kleines Display. Man könnte halt
mit einer Kamera das Display abfüllen.
OCR drauf, ja.
Wir müssen uns mal in der nächsten Folge
dediziert über Home Assistant unterhalten.
Ich würde mal mit den Picks weitermachen und dann langsam zum Ende kommen.
Kieran, was ist dein Pick der Woche?
Ich habe mir zum einen was für OpenS-Cut rausgesucht,
weil ich in letzter Zeit sehr viel Spaß mit OpenS-Cut hatte.
Das ist so ein Tool, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es kennt.
Nein.
Um Cut, also 3D-Modelle oder auch 2D,
aber primär geht es mir um 3D, zu beschreiben.
Aber in der Form von einer, ich glaube, OpenS-Cut steht für Script.
Aber ich würde es nicht als Script-Sprache bezeichnen,
aber du hast quasi eine Art Programmiersprache,
in dem du das Modell beschreibst.
Also quasi Post-Script für 3D-Drucker.
So könnte man es zusammenfassen quasi.
Das ist 3D-Modellierung für so Programmierer,
die halt nur Text können.
Ja, und vor allen Dingen so sehr einfach
parametrisierbare Modelle beschreiben kannst,
weil du quasi alles in Variablen rausziehen kannst.
Also mir fällt es immer am leichtesten,
ich habe auch ein paar Sachen schon mit Fusion
beziehungsweise mit OnShape
beziehungsweise mit anderen Cut-Tools gebaut
und das Erste, was ich immer machen möchte,
erstmal Variablen definen für meine ganzen Maße
und dann wird das modelliert
und dann kann ich diese Variablen im Nachhinein noch anfassen.
Und das ist mit OpenS-Cut natürlich super
easy. Und ich habe mir jetzt Spaß
und zwar mal alle meine Möbel in OpenS-Cut
im Wohnzimmer zusammengepasst.
Du hast neulich gepostet, dass dir noch Stühle fehlen.
Ja, die Modelle
dazu. Die habe ich vergessen, die sind mir im Nachhinein
aufgefallen. Und so kann man
schön arrangen auf dem Tisch und schauen, wie viele
alternative Layouts meines Wohnzimmers ausschauen.
Aber es hat einfach Spaß gemacht und ich wollte mich generell mal
ein bisschen auseinandersetzen.
Und so bin ich dem mal ein bisschen näher gekommen der Welt
und bin unterwegs auf zwei coole Sachen
gestoßen. Zum einen
ein WebAssembly-Build von
OpenScut, dass du das direkt
im Browser
den Compiler sozusagen ausführen kannst
und die Visualization dazu.
Und da hat auch jemand schon ein Viewer und Editor drum herum
gebaut, dass du einfach links und Editor rechts
die 3D-Ansicht hast. Und das läuft
sogar performanter als die App, weil
das schon ein paar neue Optimizations mit drin hat,
die der App noch fehlen.
ich nutze auch die App nicht, also die App hat einen schrecklichen
Editor eingebaut, aber du kannst den Editor Gott sei Dank ausschalten
und einfach die Dateien in dieses Code öffnen
links daneben und den Editor nur als View
benutzen und
es gibt ein fantastisches
Framework, das muss ich auch noch verlinken, namens
Bosel, Bosel 2
das ist
quasi eine Art
Standard Library
es ist quasi eine Art Library für
OpenS CAD, wo du haufenweise
sehr praktische Shapes
und Masken und Sachen mit rausziehen kannst,
gerade wenn du jetzt einen Cube mit abgerundeten Ecken haben möchtest.
Was, ich will nicht sagen, erstaunlich kompliziert ist,
aber erstaunlich mit dem Brust hinten, wie sagt man immer,
Pfeil durch die Brust ins Auge.
Von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge.
Genau, so musst du dir das quasi vorstellen,
wenn du ein abgerundetes,
ein abgerundeten Würfel zeichnen möchtest mit Bordmitteln,
ohne da jetzt in die Details drauf einzugehen.
Da gibt es ein paar Methoden, wie man das angehen kann.
Oder man nutzt einfach sowas wie Bosel und stellt sich ein Cuboid
und gibt die Rounding-Parameter mit und da ist das mit drin.
Und das machst natürlich, oder gerade so
Schrauben zum Beispiel oder so Sachen
macht es dir so viel einfacher,
weil du es einfach davon rausziehen kannst. Und weil es
halt Code ist, kannst du einfach
eine Library reinziehen. Und das ist halt
schon ziemlich cool.
Das ist mein einer Pick, die zwei
OpenScut-Dinge.
Und mein anderer Pick hat damit gar nichts zu tun.
Und ich sehe gerade, ich habe den gar nicht verlinkt in den
Show Notes. Das ist ein wunderschönes, cooles
Projekt namens Feed Me Up Scotty.
habe ich letztens auf Hacker News gefunden.
Die Idee dahinter ist, wir haben schon häufiger über RSS gesprochen,
ich bin ein sehr großer Fan von RSS.
Und das hier ist ein kleines Tool, was jemand gebaut hat mit der Idee,
dass du Seiten, die kein Feed haben, einfach ein paar CSS-Selektoren
in der Tommeldatei hinlegst.
Das Ganze lässt du in einer CI laufen.
So etwas wollte ich schon mal selber bauen.
Sorry, red weiter.
Ja, das ist wunderschön.
Und das Ganze lässt du aber hier, das kommt auch dazu,
in der CI laufen, beispielsweise gleich auf GitLab
oder GitHub Actions
und der generiert dann einfach
quasi einen statischen RSS-Feed mit der
Cron-Execution von der CI.
Also keine Ahnung, jede halbe Stunde,
vielleicht zwei Mal am Tag, reicht ja wahrscheinlich meistens aus
für den meisten Content und
läuft da durch, zieht über die CSS-Selektoren
den Content raus, baut daraus
einen statischen RSS-Feed und den kannst du dann
wieder konsumieren aus deinem RSS-Feed heraus.
Für die unglaublich
schick von der Art und Weise,
wie das ausgeführt wird und wie das dann läuft
über die Automatisierung.
Feed me up, Scotty. Muss ich dem
definitiv mit verlinken.
Abgefahren. Ich habe einen total
banalen,
total banalen,
unnützlichen Pick, den ich
aber total süß fand. Und zwar gibt es ein
GitHub-Repository, das heißt
Enemy Girls Holding Programming Books.
Und ich habe gerade in unseren Channel schon eins gepostet,
das ist irgendeine bestimmte
Charaktere von irgendwas, die ich natürlich nicht
kenne. Shomya,
Chiori, Holding,
Shy,
Ada95 from the beginning.
Das ist original.
Ada95 from the beginning Buchheld
oder andere Charaktere.
Ich finde es erstaunlich, was es hier alles für Sprachen
gibt in diesem Repository.
Also tatsächlich CoffeeScript gibt es noch dabei
und bei CoffeeScript gibt es natürlich nur
ein Buch an der Stelle, aber es gibt
eben eine Charaktere, die das gerade liest.
Es gibt die...
Es gibt eine Sprache, die heißt Beef.
Da höre ich gerade zum ersten Mal von.
Wondering Witch Beef
Was es denn hier alles gibt
Ich bin immer wenn
irgendwas obskur genug ist, dass A da dabei ist
muss ich nachschauen
ob es auch für D was gibt
Es gibt ein
UEFI
Buch
Harnessing the
UEFI Shell
Also dieses Repo ist einfach
lustig und wenn ihr gerade eins dieser Bücher
tatsächlich lest
dann könnt ihr euch quasi dieses Anime Girl
daneben auf dem Bildschirm anmachen, so ein bisschen
Lo-Fi-Hip-Hop und dann das Buch weiter.
Was es nicht alles gibt.
Oh man.
Ich glaube, an dieser Stelle können wir
einen Zappen zumachen. Wir haben
zweieinhalb Stunden geredet.
Das ist schon wieder eine sehr exzessive
akronische Silberfolge. Auch der Tatsache geschuldet,
dass wir einen sehr
gut informierten Gast haben,
den wir unbedingt noch für ein zweites Mal einladen müssen,
weil wir hatten eigentlich noch andere Themen,
unter anderem Home Assistant auf unserer Liste, aber
den können wir mal eine eigene Folge finden.
Ich glaube, das braucht eine eigene Folge von dem, was ihr beide
da macht.
Insofern
würde ich mich bei allen bedanken,
die bis hierhin durchgehalten haben oder vielleicht bis hierhin
übersprungen haben in den Chapter Marks.
Ah, ich gehe einfach direkt zu den Pigs, mal schauen.
Ich empfehle euch, geht noch mal
vor zu dem Ader-Teil, der ist trotzdem
interessant.
Vielen Dank, Johannes, dass du hier warst.
Vielen Dank für deine Insights.
Sehr gern, es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Und wir machen das hoffentlich bald nochmal.
Und weil du unser Gast bist und fünf Jahre absent warst von diesem Podcast,
darf ich dir den Schlusssatz überlassen, unseren Countdown.
Der nächste Podcast in eurer Podcatcher beginnt in...
Drei, zwei, eins...